morning everybody and welcome to this
meeting of Planning Committee be mayor
first we'll remind you some domestic
arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside of this meeting
room if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room by
following the fire exit signs and meet
in the Ipswich Town Football Club
training pitch and do not re-enter the
building until you're told it's safe to
do so please switch off all your mobile
phones or turn into silent like to
remind everyone present this meeting
will be broadcast live to the Internet's
more capable of repeated viewing the
whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting will be
deemed by the council so consented to
being filmed and sort of possible use of
those images and sound recordings for
webcasting or training purposes is
everybody happy of that thank you
first of all i'm barry humphries
councillor barry humphries
I'll be the chair for today it's my
first full Ches please be gentle I'm
sure it'll run really smoothly and on my
right of impress who is our legal or
planning lawyer and to the right have
Phillip Isbell who's the chief planning
officer firm it's at the district
council it's a my left Robert Carmichael
who's the governance officer John Paton
G is the area planning manager and then
we have the planning offices today
Daniel Cameron and Alex Scott to your
right we have ward members and to your
left we have the committee members who
will be voting on the proposals and
fretless today we're about to do that
we'll move on to the agenda
apologies for absences and substitutions
Thank You chair
we have apologies today from councillor
Carter councillor Guthrie and councillor
Richardson and we have three substitutes
today of
councillor Mansell forecaster Carter
councillor Brewster for councillor
Guthrie and councillor having him for
councillor Richardson
thank you to receive any decorations
pecuniary or non-pecuniary interest by
members having thank you yes I'm nan
scenery on item 70 the chestnuts farm I
I note the applicant thank you any of
these declarations of lobbying by
members to which items item 7b
application DC 1805 six to one minus 70
any declarations or personal site visits
and we'll just go for confirmation of
the minutes of the meeting held on the
son August 2019 by page page 1 just to
point out there has been a correction to
the copy that the chair has that
counseling man Matheson is now on there
apologies for the incorrect attendance
on there
no problem page 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
and 12 and to receive notifications or
petitions in accordance with the council
okay all those in favor of the mates
please
someone was not there on that occasion
yeah thanks receive notification of
petitions in the courts for the
council's petition scheme none received
yet now go through the scheduler
planning applications on this we will go
in the audience in front of you going
from seven alpha all the way through to
7th Delta in that order first one or the
first agenda point is DC one eight zero
five five one four lands south of
pressing an Avenue in baton I'm starts
on page 17 of your papers playing
officer please
thank you since watching the report a
further two letters maintaining their
objections regarding the amended scheme
have been received from residents who
have also previously commented so no new
issues have been raised in these letters
that haven't been raised previously we
have representations from eight
addresses it's about 14 letters in total
in respect of the report a couple of
points to to add firstly the site is
grayed free agricultural land common to
Suffolk but he's not the more valued
grade 1 or grade 2 in the recommendation
on page 37 1f seeks the securing of a
service site and parking for the
community hall this should say public
parking so the public the Republic needs
to be inserted there and also this is
for a 5 year period only as an option
while other locations are possibly being
considered so if after that 5 year
period of time it is not taken up as an
option then it will be secured as public
open space the details and timing to be
agreed with the local planning authority
also just to add to that the extensive
area of the parking associated access
and footprint of the community center as
shown on the indicative plan is the area
to be secured or otherwise for open
space so the recommendation just needs
to be adjusted to reflect that it is
public parking and a period of five
years for securing the site for
Community Hall and parking and if this
would be the extent of area as shown on
the indicated plan equivalent open space
but obviously the details of that will
be picked up by the 106 and of course
the reserve matters as both landscaping
and layout are not part of the outline
before you just also for the avoidance
of doubt I apologize there's quite a few
things before we get on with the
presentation for the avoidance of doubt
35% affordable housing of 85 units is
twenty nine point seven five
so in this case we've been chosen to
round up so therefore we have 30
affordable units we have not rounded
down this application also returns to
committee after previously being
deferred for some amendments and this
includes a reduction of units the case
officer has summarized these changes on
page 17 for your convenience I saw 17
and 18 of the report and hopefully
that's a helpful summary there right so
turning to the actual presentation so
the site is adjacent to the settlement
boundary south of the main core of
bactin this plan shows the various
constraints but within the site itself
is only a footpath along the top north
west or east corner okay so the footpath
not very clear on here is that line
there which leads over a railway line
and of course there there is another
footpath nearest by which is this one
that runs down this Lane here but in
terms of other constraints there are no
other constraints in planning terms we
need to be careful on the actual site
itself but let's come out a bit we are
in the countryside this is a greenfield
site it is adjacent to a railway and
across the railway there is a Sports
Club there is a open crossing across the
railway that is in existence closer in
we can see the railway a little bit
clearer which is this the site is
essentially contained by the way away
line in a sense in terms of its east and
Selvin boundaries in terms of the wider
landscape to the west we have strong
landscaped fields mature landscaping
a field access network so we've got
quite a strong landscaped area here and
a pond in in the middle of this which is
also well landscaped this application is
outlined permission for up to 85
dwellings and a community building and
associated works only access is included
so all other matters are reserved there
is an access for the housing which is
just here new proposed improvement we
also have an access for the community
center here and between the two there's
an essentially emergency access which
seems quite logical coming from the
housing out to where the community
access Community Hall access will be the
so again the actual density is 17.8
swellings per hectare if you take the
whole site but if you just take the
built-up area as indicative and shown it
will be about twenty five point nine
dwelling per hectare and obviously page
28 provides more details of the scheme
in detail and the many benefits to be
secured by planning condition I
understand members have been on site and
so they've had the benefit of site visit
but just running through that is the the
end of prettiman Avenue that's the new
access point for the main housing
development through those
and we're looking at the the field
beyond
this is an outline but the indicative
plan does demonstrate at least one way
forward for a development that would not
result in significant adverse impact on
the landscape residential amenity and
would maintain the character not
dissimilar to the adjacent development
which sufficient open space potential to
give the new development a strong wall
edge boundary that could be achieved on
all sides
the harvester 40 do not object and
recommend conditions there is one access
to serve the 85 dwellings and local
concern is on this basis has been
considered the standard adoption is for
two accesses would be if it was a
development of over 150 dwellings but
there are exceptions and far higher
numbers have actually been approved this
proposal is very much below that trigger
point for two access points for the
residential element but despite this
there's still an emergency access that
has also been included the future of the
local bus service is unclear that's been
noted by the parish council but despite
this fact in itself continues to have
offer many facilities including clubs
school pubs shop and service station in
a reasonable and well-connected
accessible distance this particular site
is adjacent to the settlement boundary
not isolated and subject to layout would
appear to be very capable of integration
to the current built form of the village
over time with appropriate conditions
106 the recommendation is one of
approval thank you thank you do you have
any questions yes can Samantha Thank You
chair I would like to ask the officer if
Network Rail were consulted because this
site is adjacent to an unmanned
pedestrian crossing of the railway and I
know that they've had a lot of plans to
close those specifically on the mainline
and I wondered what the network rail
solution to the closure of the possible
potential closure of that pedestrian
crossing next to this development is
thank you
we have no response from Network Rail
available for us to consider ultimately
we have no knowledge whether or not that
crossing will close or not as planning
offices so the assumption would be that
it would remain open cosa matheson thank
you Jeff
yet the I'd the benefit of the site
visit and in any day the the earlier
committee hearing as a member and what I
was wondering was do we have we any
understanding why when when the the
second entrance was was introduced into
these amended plans why that hasn't been
used as the main entrance for the site
with perhaps the other the coldest at
becoming the emergency access rather
than what's happening because Masuku
just feel a bit clearer on that question
please thank you when when we visited
the site several councilors including
myself said that surely surely this
little piece of meat Suffolk owned land
would provide a better ancients to this
site than the one that's proposed and so
I was interested to see that that was
now in the plans except that it was only
to access the potential community center
rather than the reorienting the whole
site so that became the main entrance
unfortunately I don't know I'm not the
case officer I don't know the ownership
issues that might be involved in the in
the two little bits land but of course
if MIT Suffolk has an interest as a
landowner they may as a organization
separate for masters local planning
authority may have put forward
particular constraints of how they would
have allowed
travel across that piece of land and
that might have only been relevant to a
community center rather than the housing
itself I don't know what private
agreement or negotiations have happened
outside of planning ultimately though
what we have in terms of your planning
application before you is an outline
application with two accesses while we
have one lay out on the table that
demonstrates one way of working it there
is nothing to say you couldn't have a
different balance of properties being
served off one access or the other that
could be considered it reserved matter
stage there was just two access points
as part of the proposal before you not
necessarily the quantum of development
served off each access because of having
thank you on page 26 and join our own
sustainability people have recommended
refusal how much time wait can we give
their opinion
the amount of weight you Pavelich give
that is obviously a matter of your
discretion in terms of what we're saying
here is we have to consider the current
local plan and its current requirements
and therefore we have not at this
outline stage giving it a significant
weight in the context of your current
development plan we have got conditions
on energy efficiency I believe they'll
just double-check to cover that point
off which is second pay thank you it's
on page 38 thank you and on that basis
we feel we have done sufficient to
respond to that that caused consultation
response that's Norris so good on page
44 excuse me top right the emergency
access where it says bollards on
emergency access just interested to ask
are these the type of followers that
retract in response to transponders on
the emergency vehicles I don't know the
answer to that question ultimately
that's a matter of detail that would be
picked up on as a reserve matter
touch Matson yeah ID for the aerial map
possibly all the young or one of the
other maps really could you show us
where the the village hall the existing
village hall the shop and the school are
on the Hat please
leave it to later this direction isn't
it
so school and the finish the store what
we aren't we have to probably not
so that there's the this store and
server station are down this direction I
think a figure at this point or slightly
further we have the school that is
roughly around here at this point
village hall I don't know can I thank
you thank you yes John if you can move
back to where you were hovering with the
mouse a second ago yes in that area
you've got both village shop and pub
just for the record and the village hall
I believe from memory if you go north
you've been indicating the school just
north side of the road there's there's
over the tall in that area little
further east of that John East not West
yeah so in that sort of area so does
that assist I think some of this is
going to come up with the ward member
when the ward members speak so I'm sure
we'll wait to learn if hasn't been
answered we'll come back to jump are
there any other questions for the
officer castle wall boy
impact on of the development on HS
kingdom they say that the there's
insufficient capacity and it's also when
it comes to schooling talks about the
impact on the secondary school and as
well as the primary school but in your
recommendations you only mention the
school contributions to the primary
school is there a reason for that that
the NHS and the secondary school are
mentioned as well in respect of those
other elements it would be a case of a
community infrastructure levy would pick
those up as opposed to search from 106
that's why we've not gone into detail on
that so this is a later it would be food
a big food community infrastructure levy
that they would obtain funds as
necessary for the secondary school and
the NHS as they may wish thank you
if it helps councillor on page 72 you'll
see at the top of county advice to
ourselves you'll see it's a rough
summary table with a split of section
106 and sell items in that and that
hopefully makes clear well it's clear
was these things can be the difference
between two items thank you there are no
further questions I'm sure there'll be
more as we go through the speakers I
will move on to the speakers please and
we have Richard Petey from the parish
council flight come up stir and just
take the table at the far end closest to
you I miss Pete you have three minutes
from the time you start and I will give
you a reminder towards the end if you're
not finishing thank you you have seen
our response of the Olympic of July in
your previous planning submission in
your briefing papers I was going to say
little has changed other than a
reduction the number of dwellings you've
probably got surprise on us with this
five-year limitation on the amenity land
or stroke Reserve site for possible
register into parish hall whatever
and we've not as a parish council been
able to discuss that so I would reserve
the right to come back off there our
next meeting to comment on that if at
all possible we resolved on the 19th to
object to this application and our
concern is one that's been discussed
already the vehicle access to the
dwellings as seen on your previous
presentation those photographs showed
what the entrance is like now although
parking restrictions are requested or
experienced elsewhere in the village for
example outside the primary school is
that the police did not take any
enforcement action even if we request
them you Darwin 1 1 or it is 1 1 3 and
you hang on for 25 minutes and don't get
a response so even if you want to try
and object to an illegal park you can't
access on foot to local facilities is
possible however as public transport to
the area is now only two or three buses
a day and may soon disappear completely
travel to work or training will be
mainly by car and I think the
contribution of 25,000 pounds for two
new bus stops might be better spent
elsewhere and if the committee resolved
to support this application we request
the Suffolk County Council highways and
District Council to tating housing
demands are met in full and written into
session 2 7 9 and section 1 of 6
agreements respectively and so that's
the current view of the parish council
thank you really questions for the
parish council kelsa having said I'm
sorry I know you've said it in there can
you staff I how many buses do you have a
day at the moment we have three in one
direction and two in the other direction
okay thank at the moment that's how it
sounds
the one early in the morning by
lunchtime in one direction only and then
another buses in the evening okay thank
you
are there any other questions thank you
sir
our second speaker is an object and
that's Carol Millwood if you'd like to
come forward please
and again you have three minutes no
reminders get towards the end thank you
can you hear me yes I'm not only
speaking for myself I'm speaking for
several other residents and many of them
are elderly this site has a major
problem for development the access the
proposed access is situated at the rear
of an existing estate it's well
established of a hundred and forty
houses and bungalows mixed traffic would
be required to travel through this
residential area to reach a narrow
entrance the proposed 85 houses would be
adjacent to an existing development
making a development of over two hundred
and twenty buildings and mid suffix call
strategy new developments should be
appropriate in scale I don't think this
would be appropriate in scale the report
from Suffolk County highways are just
number crunching and complying with
government requirements but let's get
real here 150 to 200 extra cars will
make an adverse impact and I live there
and I'm aware of the problems now if you
read objector Paul badshah's
correspondence you will see he travels a
lot and he knows the problems there will
be how can we guarantee public transport
there's going to be little or no and I'm
for the charity budget will address that
the residents travel packs they're
well-intentioned but in reality
questionable this side is not near
anything cars will be used and when it's
raining with a young man with children
they're not going to look at their
residents travel path they're going to
get the car out
the government's planning framework and
mid suffix own pledge and recently the
United Nations have urged us to minimize
car journeys to reduce co2 emissions
this site will not help if I was unable
to use my car I could not live there and
I live adjacent to that site bactin has
approval for five other sites all are
smaller and all have their own access so
I think baton is contributing to the
housing crisis the village hall
you've heard the Parrish comments will
this ever be built I'm not sure I
probably don't have the time to go into
the sustainability of proposals for one
for two but I really don't think it
stands out so I'm hoping the committee
will look very carefully and our
objections and turn this down thank you
thank you yes excellent timing to have
any questions can Samantha I do have a
question but I think it's for the
officer rather than the speaker and I
hope I'm allowed to ask this question
that the speaker referred to other
planning developing in backed in which
have got permission and I just wonder
whether the officer is able to point
those out on a map where they are and
how many houses there yes that's
reasonable we can do that
what appointment we can't name them
right so I remember we the the sites are
where the school and the school used to
be you've got the is it sixty-five
houses there that were approved and then
we've got this site opposite to that on
the same row which again is a similar
number I know actually it's less number
there are 48 we've got the reserve
matters in for that at the moment and
has been so it's got outline but it's
the reserved matters those come
so that's at that end I see if it was
down so you only got 81 there was one of
you so majority of those are this end of
the village at this moment of time you
can carry so so yes you've got we fought
an appeal in July on a sized land North
Church Road in bactin which members had
had overturned a decision of well
remembered members had overturned a
recommendation of officers so that was
for up to 81 dwellings and that decision
was allowed so that's a relatively
recent piece of development so that's
that's the site I believe close to the
junction where the shop and the pub are
from from recollection I haven't got the
application sight in front of each end
so I've got a decision but not that site
location plan so it's in that part of
the village I think that's fine all the
offices they don't know everything all
the time and I think they've done a fair
representation was relevant no I'm not
disputing that they're not quite sure of
the exact numbers but that was three I
think the the resident mentioned five so
do you know where the other two are I
don't need to know details I just will
just know where they were so the short
answer is without the without missus
Millward clarifying precisely way she's
talking right it's difficult to be
certain
from our perspective there are a number
of proposals in a locality both this
side of the railway line and the other
and you'll doubt should call there was
an application site further up towards
the the motor garage on the road towards
Finnegan that's part of development you
might associate with this village so
there's there's quite a number of
schemes that come forward in recent
years the most obvious and most recent
and relevant one I would say is the
appeal allowed in relation to church Rev
Acton and that's next to the manor house
so is it that that sort of locality down
to the
southwest of this part of the village
thank him
we welcome back to that point obviously
when we speak to the world member so he
will have a definite knowledge of the
local area any other questions
thank you we will now hear from the
applicants for occasion which is mr.
John Jennings
I see yours yourself three minutes thank
you
thank you the amended application before
you seeks to address the reasons for the
previous develop control committees
resolution to defer the application
firstly a second access has been secured
to the east of the main access and will
serve both to propose community building
and the play area this will result in a
meaningful reduction in traffic
movements through the main site access
another issue is the farm access through
the development has been deleted in
terms of site for a village hall this is
the only application either approved
under consideration within bactin which
is proceeding to provide such a facility
if this facility is not required by the
parish council parish council it will be
made available to other community groups
or offered an additional public open
space the car park to serve this
facility is to be constructed in for the
posle to close the pedestrian crossing
over the railway line is subject to an
ongoing public inquiry however if this
cross encloses network rail will be a
bla obligated to provide alternative
arrangements the amended application is
supported by a revised travel plan
transport assessment and school travel
plan the additional homes would create
additional demand to support the bus
services bus services serving bactin and
as part of the travel plan put forward
the travel plan coordinator will work
for the bus operators to increase their
services it is important to note at this
juncture that the highest authorities
have advised that the development would
not be prevent should not be prevented
or refused from higher glance as there
are no unacceptable impacts on Highway
Safety and the question of the previous
committee we have reduced a number of
dwellings from 100 to 85 dwellings a
reduction of 15% this change allowed to
the provision of separate access to the
community building has clearly
demonstrated a significant reduction in
traffic flows through the main access
point resulting in further improvements
to residential amenity whilst scale of
development has been reduced the
proposal is still committed to providing
many benefits including 35% of
affordable housing including a high
number of bungalows both affordable and
open market importance bungalows is
recognized by recent report to your full
council as being a particular form of
housing with image mid Suffolk where
there is a severe shortage and this is
40 by paragraph 10 at the National
Planning Policy framework
residential amenity is reinforced by the
bearing of the existing overhead power
lines and incorporation of bungalows
together with a 10 meter
landscape buffer the Lando's landowners
will accept a condition restricting the
dwellings on the northern boundary to
single-story properties only the fair
water pumping station has been relocated
southwest corner site away from
dwellings the applicants are committed
to the early delivery of this site and
have received strong expression
expressions of interest from a number of
local and regional house builders this
development will provide a meaningful
contribution towards maintaining the
council's housing land supply as advised
by your officer the majority of local
services are with ingredient walking and
cycling distance of the site providing a
sustainable network connection via
existing designated safe foot ways which
are lit if you are the parties
considered the proposal has fully
address the reasons for the previous
deferral and is requested that committee
now approved this application in
accordance with your office's
recommendations thank you
five seconds out very good thank you
have we got any questions please for the
agent councillor Mansell sorry again
this might be a question for the
officers the speaker has just talked
about landscape buffers and high
proportion of bungalows and I know that
the title of this application is
outlined some matters reserved but I
presume that the bungle out the housing
mix in terms of bungalows and the
landscape buffer are part of the reserve
matters and not part of the outline can
I have that confirmed please two points
there that drew my attention wanders
bungalow as you obviously that would be
a matter reserved matters the the
housing mix both market and affordable
housing is a condition in your
recommendation I think point three on
the recommendation of conditions so we
would maintain control over the mix and
tenure of all properties coming forward
it was a matter stage so that is still
to play for in effect I'm just picking
up on the the the height restriction was
mentioned on the northern boundary we
have not got that as a condition in any
form it might be something the members
wish to pick up at in debate and if that
is the case maybe I can come back
to you or the chief planning officer can
come back to you on that basis if you
wish to explore that any further thank
you any of the questions
because of medicine yeah just just to
clarify that point absolutely that from
mr. payment gee that the the under the
recommendation b-1b there on page 37 so
you're saying that the the control of
mix is of the site rather than of the
affordable part it's for both market and
affordable that's open to the whole site
thank you any more questions
thank you thanks sir and now we moved to
the ward member which is councillor
Andrew Mellon Andrew thank you chair I
hope you leave those away I'm going to
make five basic points and these are
reasons why I believe this application
should be turned down and the first one
is that is that I don't believe that the
applicants have don't adequately with
the concerns the committee expressed
with the first application the access is
still unclear and the applicant intends
to use one main entrance for the
residential houses which seems to me is
not adequate when there's a possibility
of having too
on the public transport we have a
problem in impacting in that basically
we've seen over the years a diminution
of the bus service we used to get seven
or eight buses a day we now have two or
three mini buses a day not buses and
that service is under review it's
support from the counter counters under
review
we had no timetable confirmed beyond
September so it would seem to me rather
odd if we had two new bus stops
constructed and no buses on the railway
crossing this railway crossing has not
been confirmed that it will be closed
and yet the developer is proposing a
play area next to what I consider to be
a dangerous crossing I've seen people
using that crossing very unwisely
there's no there's no gates or anything
that would stop people getting onto it
so it's a real concern about people
using a play area next to an open
crossing and then we come to the village
hall or the potential community facility
so my mind this is offered as a
sweetener but there's been no
consultation with the community about
where or whether a new village hall as
required at the last count backs and has
something like seven or eight public
meeting rooms that people can use in the
church in the in the the surgery in the
scouter in the football club so there's
a multiplicity of public meeting rooms
in the village and we already have a
village hall now there has been a
concern expressed about the the village
hall going forward needing to be
improved and possibly on to a new site
with better parking but the working
assumption and this includes informal
discussions with Tony basses and officer
of the council that when the primary
school closes and we don't know when
that will happen that the building
currently used by the under thighs would
become the new village hall this is the
sort of working assumption in the
village so in all those things which
cause the committee to previously defer
the application I don't feel that though
they've been adequately adequately
address in this new application if I can
move on to my second point and this is
the fact that we already have a large
number of homes approved for
construction in bactin and I will just
go through them just to confirm this
discussion earlier we have opposite the
middle school 64 homes without line
reserved matters current currently under
consideration Turkey Hall Lane wasn't
mentioned 51 homes without lying
permission next to the manor 81 up to 81
which is the subject of the the recent
public inquiry broad Rose this is the
road going towards Finnegan 47 houses
approved that application is about to
lapse and they're putting a new
application for 66 so we're already
around the 250 houses approved in Batam
alongside that we had the site at the
middle school which is still under
negotiation and the application is still
sort of basically a stalled site
currently it doesn't have approval
subjects in negotiations with the county
council so there's another 50 homes
there so if we're talking about 300
homes already in the pipeline for
bouncing according to the the joint
local plan Backson is expected to
provide a minimum of 225 homes over the
next 18 years so you can already see
that batten is making a significant
contribution to local development and
where we to add another 85 we can see
why residents have concerns about local
amenities being stretched my third point
is about the residential immunity of the
houses next to the access there's five
houses facing directly onto this
cul-de-sac
it's a quiet area at the back end of
estate for those people I can't see how
we can avoid changing their residential
amenity negatively
a currently deer facing onto a quiet
cul-de-sac that would become a
thoroughfare into the new estate so I
have real concerns about the five houses
their council heading and brought up the
sustainability concerns which are on the
top of page 26 of your papers it seems
to me that the developer has failed to
engage with the sustainability concerns
expressed by the two offices there and
my last point is this we are now in a
very different situation to when this
original application came in Miss
Suffolk now has a solid five year land
supply and this site was not appeared in
any kind of sh la la laa Assessment it's
not part of any allocation and not
included in the extended settlement
boundary under the emerging joint local
plan so I suggest that this application
has to be considered has to be dealt
with and should be turned down thank you
thank you any questions please no okay
thank you so now moving to debate on
this subject I'd like to start
councillor Mansell in the absence of
anybody else wishing to make a start I
have my concerns about the need for this
development and I was quite shocked to
read in the officer report on page 36 in
the summary I think that is that it says
car dependency will be low because it
appears to me that bactin has a
diminishing bus service and yeah okay
it's got a primary school and a little
village shop but I'm sorry people who
move into this development in fact
anyone who probably moves into bactin
will require the use of a car so I think
it's a little bit wrong
to print that it put that in print we've
heard about the other developments in
bactin which one of them I gather is
coming up for reserve matters I presumed
none of them I've got any beyond that as
the ward member says there are 250 ODS
possibly more houses already got
planning permission in back turn and it
is going to intensify the use of the car
because the bus unless we do something
about the bus service it does seem like
there's a little point in spending a
load of money on providing some bus
stops if there are no buses to stop at
the bus stops and we have no control
over the buses that is not within our
remit so although this might seem a
well-thought-out plan with some
bungalows and a sweetener of a of a
community space again that seems to have
been not enough thought putting as to
whether this is really necessary so I
and I guess the other houses that I've
got planning permission in bactin most
of those probably got permission whilst
we didn't have a five-year land supply
and perhaps this one is surplus we do
now have our five-year land supply so
does back to need another 85 houses
probably not so at the moment I'm I'm
veering towards not wanting to support
this application but I will await to see
what anyone else on the committee has to
say thank you before we go any further
mr. Isabel I think thank Jamie yes sir
can I can I just pick up on that
five-year length of like point just
before there's any misunderstanding
flows from this as has been mentioned
there was some discussion at appeal
relatively recently and indeed an
inspector allowed Planning Commission on
the 81 site as mentioned he did consider
both public transport issues and a range
of other things which we may all come on
to knew in the course of debate but
certainly he did not devour further
development he acknowledged that we
could demonstrate a five-year housing
land supply but he said that does not
place a ceiling on further sustainable
development he talked to a number other
things including transport choices and
was content that Planning Commission be
granted and there will be a range of
benefits from the developments so you
know I'll hesitate before commenting
further but certainly as regards
five-year land supply we may have a
fountain inland supply inspectors can be
expected to recognize that but
nonetheless considered the merits anyway
so I would be wary of considering that
that allows the district to draw a line
in the sand as it were thank Jamie
councillors for debate coach maths yeah
I do think we needed to have had a
clearer picture of the Kim you know the
cumulative numbers and the cumulative
impact that these might have I think
that's that's my particular particular
concern about this and a knife on the
the point about sustainability the the
officer there has say has been quite
critical to that to the point of saying
that the the applicant has not really
engaged with the gatineau of that
somewhere with the the NPP F and what
that's got to say and I've wanted to
particularly draw attention to
paragraphs 148 150 and wonder how this
this particular development proposal
contributes to mitigating climate
changes it doesn't seem to have had any
any particular room offer to
you know to improve its sustainability
given what we've heard that all right
well there are some buses at the moment
but not very many and no sir because
reality is the reality is as I said your
points were made but this is outline
planning permission so that we can
actually we we obviously have put a
condition in to see sustainability
measures to be considered concurrently
with the visitor matters when it's
submitted this is the point of until you
actually know what the layout is and the
design of the actual properties how do
you get into their merits in terms of
their sustainability credentials on a
range of factors at this moment at this
juncture and I appreciate what the MPP F
says I also have to appreciate what our
development plan lacks in that context
and I have to balance the two so this is
far as we think we can do without being
unreasonable
having him thank you
I too have my doubts about this this
development
thinking that you know it seems to be a
long way from the shops and the school
but I really I'm struggling to find any
any planning reason why we can unturn it
down really you know that like the
sustainability thing is a bit of a worry
but like John says that's really you
know coming up later that we can um you
know put any conditions on that chairman
if I can just pick up on the wider
context of this and you can imagine that
if committee do decide to overturn the
recommendation includes the application
as is a choice the question of raising
will become quite important and I would
expect where I representing the
applicant to quite heavily weigh
reliance upon the appeal decision not
that far away in the village now the
inspector in that instance was weighing
other issues including it effect on a
heritage asset and chose to place
considerable benefits on housing stocks
that will be supplied by this and he
took a view on the amount of affordable
dwellings being provided when this
within the scheme and effectively used
term bleak as regards affordability data
for the district so he took a clear view
that there were benefits to this scheme
and public benefits which in a world
consistent with the council's objectives
in the round you know from from our
perspective as offices there is a
cumulative impact the reference to the
site to the east of to the war to the
west of broad Road on the other side the
railway line that hasn't come forward
clearly the market has not chosen to
favor that for whatever reason
application is back in and clearly its
merits and it's deliverability have to
be given consideration but and my advice
to committee is always decide the
application in front of you and be aware
of of the issues that you face you have
a five-year landslide but nonetheless
there are benefits that come from this
development we are in a situation where
the amount of homes being provided here
does represent a public benefit and
there are a full complement of
affordable is available within this
scheme which are you know from our
perspective of material value in terms
of transport choices and I recognize
that there is concern over that public
transport question the inspector
elsewhere was quite content that this
was a key service centre and that there
were sustainable transport choices and
those will go up and go down and
doubtless if there are more houses there
is a higher probability one would
imagine that that question of public
transport access will become more
attractive for bus service providers and
that is ultimately a question of how bus
services are delivered else was wearing
and not within the gift of a planning
authority so from our point of view and
I would urge the committee to be very
careful in its weighing up clearly there
is a choice we exercised here but
understand that there is some of these
issues have been played out quite
recently at public inquiry and the
district was not successful in its
objection to a scheme in the village
thank general okay thanks to the
important point we need to go on what's
in front of us and what's today really
especially the bus service it could go
up we could go down we don't know we can
only read what we're reading today in
terms of this actual plan application if
you are moving towards a refusal then
obviously we need a really good reason
for that so you might want to ponder
that before anybody dis proposed and
further debate please Casa Brewster
thank mr. chairman yes listening sir all
has been said on this application this
morning we saw on page 17 and the top of
page 18 the details the previous
committee resolutions and the member
site visit it does appear to me that
most of those items have where they can
be have had been really dealt with we
was asked by members
stage access okay the the second
entrance explored for the need of the
forum access that has been dealt with
the public transport the travel plan
with the current bus services and
obviously there could well be a need for
bus services and that's an unknown
quantity it is for tomorrow I'm afraid
because the bus service is still there
at this moment in time but with bungalow
developments that would suggest to me
that they could well be taken by old
people and who may be infirm and may be
needing a bus so that that would
actually help to make a bus service more
viable there are way crossing well we
all know how easy it is to deal with
Network Rail in actual fact not easy at
all and they they they take a long time
to make their decisions the village hall
that whether the village decide they
need a new village hall is is a story
for the the parish council and and the
the community there and that whatever
that will still be conditioned as an
open space for the community so it is a
community facility section 106 hundred
consider too many for the site and we
see that that side has been reduced by
15 houses making it a little bit more
acceptable in terms of the the two
possible entrances which the ward
members spoke about actually I would be
very concerned about two entrances and
I'm sure bactin doesn't have them as we
may do in the market in places but boy
races love or something like that where
they can actually chase around the roads
and cause all sorts of problems III
think the five-year land supply is an
important one because it is what we have
at the moment is not a truly robust land
supply and we need to continue building
homes to actually increase that supply
and make it actually safer which which
some members are asking for in all those
term as mr. chairman I am certainly
moved to the direction of approving the
side and I will wait to see what I also
said but that is my opinion we good any
other points cut ago thank you Jim like
cancer hananim I find difficult to see
planning reasons for refusal within this
application I do have a a concern in
relation to the railway crossing and
fear that's basically that's itself
might become an extension of the play
area yeah what carefully I don't know
whether any measures can be taken to to
reduce mitigate that risk I'm slightly
curious in the planning history
paragraph page 19 when the Sheila
assessment found it not suitable because
of the site's poor relation to the
functional settlement as neither the
time or the scientists moved I wonder if
you could just give some reassurance on
on on on that point also thank you
before we got to your castle wall boys
I'm John you really would you would just
answer those points if we did this in
reverse order chairman if I if I leave
in Welsh Jonas is doing his thing
um the shale are is obviously a desk
based exercise so it has its limitations
and I think if you were to have
colleagues from policy team in this room
they would they would say yes it takes
you so far and it goes only so far
certainly I think you know my advice to
committee is that doesn't necessarily
allow you to draw a conclusion that it
isn't a satisfactory sight because it is
of its own innate nature a limited
exercise and I'll kind of trespass
probably on Jon's territory as well
regarding the railway crossing I mean
clearly the public already having access
to the railway crossing there's already
a sports ground not that far away one
can imagine the public children included
may well resort to that as of right I
think these cloak these closures has
colleagues on committee will will
understand I I i consider have been
raised elsewhere and are an issue but we
have to respect the fact that they are
republic right
doubtless as the reserved matters
include layout at the site one may well
seek to relocate play spaces away from
the particular location shown on this
clearly the village hall elements and
the car parking we would not expect to
relocate within reserve matters but
those those places where children may
more naturally resort we would hope to
take away and therefore they would
probably be drawn to other parts of the
village but children will be children
I'm afraid yet the case officer has also
pick back up in their planning balance
on page 36 but in respective if I can
quickly put the site plan on the screen
can you do that a moment I was just
going as a not changing
I was gonna say that while there is an
indicative leap equipped area a local
equipped area play here there is no
reason if I was just to take this
indicative plan and it is an indicative
plan at face value that that couldn't be
relocated much further away and there's
possibly two other sites much further
away from the crossing area that would
therefore mean that you perhaps have
more peace of mind about certain age
children being at one end of the
district they're heading to play on
their own and unsupervised compared to
if they were playing near the railway
line although that is obviously always a
matter of human instinct and choice
Council war boys
I'm looking at that back turn on a map
it's quite actually clear that back team
has developed along the main road and
developments taking place on lanes which
come into that road this this
development sort of is an extension of
that kind of precedent it's going beyond
the development of the road behind an
existing large estate into open
productive agricultural land this has
actually lead into problems with access
and the supporting infrastructure that's
the only access to this development is
going to be through existing estate I do
appreciate the sort of value of the
proposal proposed community center of
village hall but I am also concerned
that there seems to be a lack it even at
this stage there's a lack of
consultation as to what form that
contribution could be in policy terms
we've got nothing that says we have to
provide a community center in this site
or within this area it is an option that
the developers purely just stuck on the
table and we've taken the opportunity as
officers to secure that for five years
to do much more than that would be
unreasonable because we're kind of not
basing that on any policy requirements
as it is it allows time for those to
come forward and decide if they wish to
take that on board or not and that is an
opportunity that we were effectively
maintaining for the time being if this
was to be approved otherwise it becomes
open space but in terms of actual need
we could be argued not to require any
kind of revision at all and therefore
all we're doing is allowing the
opportunity and not losing that
opportunity we're not actually securing
a community hall at this stage Kerr
Samantha thank you I would just like to
voice my disagreement with the comment
from Council of
about these the reasons for deferral
being addressed I I'm sorry but I think
I agree more with the ward member in
that they haven't really been addressed
I think the only one that has been
addressed
is number five which is about the number
of houses being put on the site and yes
you can't deny that that has been
reduced but given that the one of the
reasons for the deferral was to
investigate the railway crossing I don't
think it has been investigated fully
enough and yes we've heard from the Cape
the officer that the play area doesn't
have to go there it could go somewhere
else but I certainly have got the
impression that the location of the
community facility is pretty much going
to be in that location and regardless of
where the play area is youths will
congregate around the community space so
they are still going to be adjacent to
the crossing and in certainly in other
applications or certainly an application
I can name there was a condition about
the closure of the adjacent railway
crossing to a development and yet
nothing of that nature seems to be here
and we've also heard about councillor
Matheson comment on to sustainability
now my issue is not with the
sustainability of the buildings but with
the sustainability of the location I'm
still not convinced that it is a
sustainable location it will increase
car dependence everyone who lives there
will be dependent on a car and in that
sense it's not sustainable we can deal
with the issues of design of the layout
reserve matters if it gets that far but
I am not yet convinced that that bactin
can sustain any more development in a
sustainable nature take care so
disturbed just from my point of view
actually on the previous committee
points that have been addressed I think
they've all been addressed apart from a
railway we've already discussed the
access that's less than hundred and
fifty dwellings you only need one access
the fact is an emergency access there as
well as additional the community centre
might not happen
we remain community space and just a
reminder on the on the railway crossing
it's currently part of the public
footpath and is used and that were rail
haven't come back to us I don't see that
the officers could do any more on that
point next person is council Norris
thank you
like Council by having them I am also
struggling to find the planning reasons
for refusing this application I have
considerable concerns about it looking
although I appreciate this is purely an
outline application at this stage but
looking at the indicated layer on page
44 and comparing to the existing
residential properties adjacent to it it
does seem very but on the urban style
development within a rural setting and
being as a character with its
surroundings
I do also still have reservations about
the proximity of the play area to the
railway cop crossing until we have more
assurances on that point and there's
regard sustainability but it's a
statement about car dependency will be
low is very difficult actually to
support as we've heard about the
restrictive public transport facilities
in the area so I am still undecided on
this one I'll wait to see if there are
any other further comments from members
cosa Matheson yeah I I can see that I
can see the difficulty in finding
reasons for refusal but I've been I was
thinking a little bit more about that
little phrase from the planning policy
team that it was pouring related to the
functional settlement and going back
again to the the five I think it was in
the end developments that are either
approved or won in the melting pot at
the moment they they are they are much
better related to the shop and the
school and so forth then
and certainly to the to the potential
future school as well and when you start
to look at the far side of this
development is actually rather a long
way away from those those services that
that people are being expected to depend
on so office isn't clearly not going to
help us
but the the looking at that and looking
at the the cumulative impact and we
haven't got a good policy that helps us
with that I'm really very reluctant to
actually you know embark on approval at
the moment thank you and which is going
to answer that point I shall give it a
little bit more weight to sort of detail
and then we'll come to you counselling
thanks Jim um just trying to get John to
get me the aerial map up so we can have
a quick look about relative distances
the there are various developments as as
you know within bactin which have been
discussed within the five it's important
to note that the it's not that one that
one yes
so clearly we discussed where the shop
and the the pub we're at the
southwestern end of the village the
broad road site is to the east of the
railway line it may well be that the
infrastructure requirements in order to
navigate under the well marked low
bridge
under the railway line have caused
people to question whether that site is
actually deliverable and as I'm well
aware from our housing delivery action
plan work delivery is the key thing for
ourselves to engage with so in terms of
you know location relative to shops
you've got a foot wide connection
through to the west and albeit this may
be of the order of 600 metres away our
regular pub wrigley passed through this
area and and people can and do regularly
use the foot way to connect from the
various parts of the village so you know
from my perspective that is entirely
likely that they will do so and broad
Road is not more convenient and would
require negotiating the bridge which was
itself the subject of an infrastructure
ask which may mean that sites never
actually deliverable so in terms of
connectivity I think there is you know
there's this there's quite a lot for our
perspective in the balance here
thank Jenny because having thank you I
was just gonna say I remember the I
think it's 481 houses the one next to
that listed property I remember at the
time I'm looking at the community of
accumulative effects of our how many
applications were in backed them at the
time and the fact that that's been
turned over by the inspector I think you
know we're really gonna struggle here so
have something that we can really sort
of stand on if we try and turn it down
and so for that reason you know with
their heavy heart I'm gonna you know
push for um recommend that we go along
with the officers recommendation so we
do have a proposal for approval second
at least I'll second that mr. chairman a
proposal and a secondary proposal for
approval customers on should this
proposal be passed would the proposed
and second to be willing to consider the
conditions suggested by the planning
officer about the height restriction on
the northern boundary if you'd like me
to speak to that first before you
consider it it was passing mention and
obviously this is an indicative layout
plan so I can't say plots ABC should be
restricted to X it would perhaps be best
to phrase it that within and I've
measured it 20 meters of the north
boundary of the site that there shall be
no development exceeding single-story
that might be the best phrase to use oh
happy Casa Matson yeah if if we're
moving in that direction the the other
the other particular note that I've got
is on page 102 that there is mention of
advanced landscaping before construction
which is something that I've asked for
many many times and we can't impose it
as a condition I'm told but on the other
hand if it's being offered can we pin it
down somehow it's not my understanding
being offered it's a recommendation from
our place Services Consultant the only
problem with advanced landscaping is it
has a habit of being bulldozed the
moment the construction team comes on
and on I would
and also landscaping at this time is a
reserve matter so there is potential for
us to look at that really at the next
stage rather than preempt what may come
forward at this point thank you so good
debate thank you for your contributions
everybody we have a proposed you have
seconded for approval all those in
agreement have then agreed the condition
so I didn't I didn't yes they did
chairman and that's with the amendments
that John mentioned at the right about
the beginning of his presentation yeah
all of that is everybody happy I was a
proposer and the second
with the conditions all those in favor
and those against yeah I have a casting
vote and I need to go with my my initial
vote which was four so approved now
moving on to agenda item 7b which is the
outline playing an application for
residential development but 243 to
Wellings 14 affordable in Jax Green Lane
treating Saint Mary Civic can all them
members please confirm they've got the
additional piece of paper that's
delivered this morning thank you
the council Norris now move over has
Ward member so Daniel if you'd like to
present please
Thank You chair yes we've got before is
an application made an outline with all
matters reserved for forty three
residential dwellings and land off track
screen world including Saint Mary
there's nothing further apart from the
late papers that came to reflect the
final comments of the Suffolk little
water team the other one the application
site is highlighted in purple on the
plan we've got it's currently a
agricultural field there's a drainage
ditch that runs across it which is
visible and photos later if we look at
this plan further out the site still in
purple but you can quite clearly see
flood zone two and three crossing the
site and that follows the line of a
drainage ditch within the site itself
you'll know the linear development along
Jack's green road to the northwest and
then the state suburban development
south the a14 runs up north to south
along the northern boundary north
eastern boundary of the site this is
just the aerial photograph showing a
little bit more context you can see the
surrounding area is predominantly rural
and character but then we have that and
strongly suburban area to the south and
then further out I'm not sure if you can
see it particularly well but we have we
have creeks and merry kilometers and
then access to need a market is
also down a footpath again sort of
similar 1.1 kilometer distance away we
move on we have the illustrative site
layout there's a area of open space
consisting of place base and also a
meadow at the north of the site that
takes up the majority of the area that
falls within flood zone 3 exception that
would still be there in a function of
for use and housing as a vulnerable use
is situated well outside of any flood
zone now if we move on to the site
photos here is the site benefits from
existing agricultural access from Jack's
green road members will see in the
distance is a clump of the veteran trees
here in the edge of the site
these are mentioned in the report and
outside of the site area such that they
would remain throughout development this
is looking the other way and this line
of scrub is one side of the drainage
ditch here's a slight looking north from
the area four teams in distance behind
the trees on the edge of the site here
is the ditch running up through the site
and then this is the area on the other
side of the ditch proposed as medical
open space and then this is a view up
towards the linear run of development to
the northwest of the site and then this
is the road looking that way as well
to the aerial layout go all matters are
reserved with this application such that
the layout is indicated only and all
matters will be back before committee we
were minded to approve for additional
scrutiny looking at the development
we're looking at a density of around 18
dwellings per hectare on this site with
delivery of additional housing 35%
policy compliant affordable housing an
additional benefits on the site based on
this recommendation and the console t
responses we've received the
recommendation before members today is
for approval subject to the agreement of
a section 106 agreement which will be
negotiated and the details of which are
included in the report thank you do you
have any questions Thank You councillor
Hedren Thank You Emma can I just really
quickly went over it there's a photo of
the watercourse can you just show that
photo again please that's it if that is
the main that's that's the drainage
ditch that runs through the site
obviously there it was quite dry day
it's quite a hot day so actually the
water levels quite low but then
obviously the flood zone data
information is based on update for
worst-case scenarios in event of
flooding events exacerbated by climate
change and show that it does have
capacity to breach the ditch and extend
out into the site but that's the reason
why in the indicated layout it's not
very visible on the screen that I'm
looking on for
but there is a sort of red line that
traverses the site if I can do it this
way just along this boundary here and
that is the edge of flood zone 3 castle
Mansell thank you I'd like to ask a
question regarding a summary of the
highways response on page 127 of the
report where it says that the high
school is in Devon um and is 7.5 miles
from the site but is that actually
correct because snow upland and Stowe
market high schools are both closer than
that so is this village really in the
catchment for debenhams I think I think
the issue here is the way that highways
comments have been worded they don't
tend to look at catchments anymore which
would be yeah potentially we could look
at a number of schools within that area
I think you're right I think the closest
probably is Debenhams but we can note
sorry Stowe upland let's get all the
words right
but no I think yes we could we could
look at that certainly but that's in
looking at the comments from suffix
infrastructure team they do know a need
for requirement for secondary school
education transport contributions and we
can look to nail down where that would
look to be delivered and how that would
look to be spent within the section 106
that would accompany and he approved
recommendation
any questions
Julia if I can just pick up on the
education right chairman I think you'll
find there's advice from County
infrastructure colleagues there what
Manas on page 163 regarding pupil yields
and school presence and that does make
reference to Devon in Amman and that
animal property and a number of other
schools generally tell so having him
sorry it's a perfect arc question really
there's a there's a black spot on the
aerial map and I can't really see on the
site layout whether that relates to a
tree or I mean is it that of a specific
tree with a teepee arrow or something on
it there's no teepee O's or other
special landscape designations affecting
the site if we that's right way is it
this one that spot I think that just
relates to the powerline so if we go
back to the photos of the site in
particular looking across to the
drainage ditch
I assume it's relating to that and just
to reiterate there are no deaf questions
that's a very good question
Kosar Matheson thank you yeah I was
rather concerned at that the number of
console tees which were flagged up with
no response I don't know that you'd like
to actually comment on that quite a lot
of them are actually internal to this
council and you know it does kind of
point towards whether you know whether
is the right time to be making the
decision and the recommendation in the
decision if we haven't heard from the
most people I think with regards to the
no responses reported in the rapport
that's just to give a full and clear
view of what console t's we have
actually gone out and saw opinions from
we have then gone and chased them to
ensure that if they have pertinent
comments to make we are in receipt of
them so we can make our decisions you
know where we have the most information
available to us there's not a
requirement for them necessarily to
respond and to report no response is
just to give
the clarity because I think actually if
we were to respond in the reports to say
no comment that's actually a very
different comment to one just not being
made and I think for clarity we want to
be clear that where people have not
responded we should be reporting that
but at the moment we feel that while we
may have some missing console T's we do
have others who have similar remix who
have picked up and have responded and
given us that information to cover that
topic yeah just to be clear on that
on the pre meeting we discussed that at
length nob satisfied actually off assist
and everything they can to try and get
responses but you can't force somebody
to respond councillor Mansell sorry I've
come up with another question I'm
terribly sorry for coming in twice can I
just have some clarification please that
the access is part of the reserved
matters in this application because I
know a lot of other outlines do include
access so the access points on the plan
is still up for grabs it's on reserved
matters yes the access point is is part
of the reserved matter so that could
move as part of any application for
outline Planning Commission they do need
to be able to show that it can make an
access to the highway and highways are
satisfied in this instance they can't do
that but that might move and change
obviously we've got the the flood zone
within the site so it's unlikely to be
moved anywhere close to that I think
we'd have a lot of issues with
Environment Agency in terms of permits
and then with floods or more in terms of
converting or bridging over so it's
probably more likely to be in the area
as shown but no he's subject to
potential movement
any other questions council war boys yes
the first council thought this would and
from the photographs it was quite clear
that there's some major power lines
running across the site what measures
will be taken to deal with that I
actually know this so I'm quite pleased
to say so the policy on the electrical
magnetic fields is
by government so all the pylons and all
the cables and everything else I've got
a certain level and that level is to
ensure that there's no harm to any
bodies from EMF activity there is a set
distance that you have to build away
from those substations and also from
cables and obviously I'm pretty sure
that come up reserved matters but
actually there is no law that says you
can't build near power cables because
they are protected against EMF against
antibodies that's that's the policy at
the moment any other questions thank you
then we'll move on to speakers so we'll
start with Paul Scully please sir
we'll put mr. scalise from the parish
council and you have three minutes and
I'll remind you when we get close to
that time you just press the button it's
got like a mouth on it on the right hand
side the connection from the new
development at Jack's green to need a
market you state can be made on foot all
the way by public footpath this is
incorrect because the footpath only goes
as far as Crown Street Bridge need a
market there after is a narrow road with
a blind spot this is the nearest route
to shops and bus stops you've also made
no reference to those who are elderly
disabled or who use wheelchairs Jack's
green road has a 30 mile per hour speed
limit but Suffolk County counts the
highways state that there are no
unacceptable impacts on highway safety
this is incorrect as shown by survey
conducted in 2013 on behalf of the
parish council over a seven-day 24 hour
a day period vehicles exceeding 30 miles
per hour was sixty five point six
percent traveling southbound and 57.2%
northbound this was unacceptable then
and will be excessive ated by the
increase in volume of traffic when
Brahimi's fifty two houses are built
further on Fordham Road the junction
widths and Mary's Gardens is already a
black spot the parish council has
recently purchased the speed activated
sign in an attempt to remind drivers to
slow down
therefore the addition of forty three
houses is totally unacceptable you state
the SIL money's will be used in part to
improve the capacity of both the local
primary school and the GP surgery in
need of marking the primary school is
full and cannot be expanded and I
understand neither can the surgery in
its current position the parking outside
the school is already congested and
dangerous at peak times this situation
is made worse on occasions when the
church holds a funeral service as it can
clash with the school pick up time we
don't tick a box for a
stop or a public-house as both are on
the i-140 which is a long way from jack
screen and indeed unusable to most
residents including some mary we also do
not tick a box for a local shop all of
these factors must be taken into account
the Parish Council acting on behalf of
the residents are against this proposal
because this Hamlet will not be improved
or enhanced in any respect on the
contrary it will convert a rural area
into a suburb of neither market which is
totally unacceptable and outrageous
thank you very much any questions for
the Parish Council I've got one you say
it's a black spot do you know how many
accidents they've been ill I say five
years thank you
Carrie Mathison yeah we do have a
question for you sir yes can I can I
just ask you a little bit about the your
fourth point there current flooding
issues would become a lot worse so
there's a drainage ditch across the site
so we're talking about downstream from
that where are the issues arising the
flood extends across the field across
Jack's screen Road all the way through
across the Mary's Road right through to
the river with nipping is there any
other questions thank you sir
now have the applicant stroke agent
which is Louise Mills please
and once again you have three minutes
thank you good morning and thank you for
agreeing to let me speak my name is
Louise Mills and I'm the clerk for
needham market and bulk and welfare
charities the landowner firstly I must
apologize that our agent is not present
this is due to unforeseen personal
circumstances I thought it might be
useful to give the committee a little
background to the land being discussed
this site was gifted to the arms at the
Alexander Arms house charity over a
century ago its specific purpose was to
provide an income to support the repair
cost of the charity's existing arms
houses and to further support the
residents within them in nineteen in the
1970s a section of land was compulsory
purchase for the a45 dual carriageway
construction now named the a14 an
agricultural lease has been in operation
for over 40 years with the same family
who at one point farmed the land with
the introduction and size of modern
farming equipment crop farming on the
land stopped many years ago as the plot
simply isn't big enough the lease offers
only what can be described as a
peppercorn rent which is swallowed up
for some years if the rent is reviewed
the site itself is located immediately
adjacent to housing on three sides with
the a14 being located on the other this
site whilst located outside of the build
envelope would provide a suitable form
of much-needed local houses and provide
an important economic benefit to the
local community the site is both close
to the a 14 and a 140 providing
excellent commuter links and is also
located in close proximity to both stone
market and Needham Market and their
associated rail links there is also a
footpath that links and connects the
proposed development site into the
neighboring village of Needham Market
trustees own four arms house is located
within the grounds of terrifical in
Needham Market which were built
following the sale of the old homes
houses in Needham Market that no longer
met modern day housing standards a
financial surplus from this their sale
exists
it is hoped that by realizing the value
of this land and adding to the surplus
additional arms houses can be built to
further the charities ability to help
its intended beneficiary whilst the plan
proposal submitted are only indicative
the outline plan the scheme has been
drawn up in accordance with current
planning legislation with guidance from
our local planning officer to whom we
are grateful every request during the
planning phase has been accommodated by
trustees to try and ensure that the
proposed scheme would meet with the
guidance of both the national and local
planning requirements the scheme
proposes a mix of 43 housing units and
at appropriate proportion of affording
house houses which is broken down as
follows 14 affordable housing of which
to us semi two beds semi-detached there
are eight three bed semi-detached there
are six open market 29 in total for bed
for two beds semi 12 three beds semi 7/3
bed detached and solitary if you could
just if this plan and application were
to be successful trustees will offer the
site for sale and has already advised
any monies raised would be reinvested to
support the charities beneficiaries
thank you for your honor any questions
please councillor Madison yeah I was a
bit bit puzzled like that you hadn't the
report on page 123 said there'd been no
pre-application advice but you thank the
officers for their help so I whether
that's me correcting or something I'm
not aware of any pre-application advice
has been sought with regards to this
site and whether or not there's been
feedback between officers and the agent
during the application that's probably
what's been referred to but not it's not
the case that we haven't reported
pre-application advice to the committee
we've actually been dealing with this
for a number of years and have had
face-to-face meetings at the ultimate
Suffolk district council offices and
numerous conversations off the record to
try and format the best plan I could
also answer the question on schooling I
know it's fine thank you any other
questions
thank you thank you time we're now hear
from the ward councillors we've got two
who would like to go first
my choice thank you
I fully support creatures at Mary parish
councils objections against this
application on page 124 of the papers
the site falls outside the settlement
boundaries of either [ __ ] Saint Mary
or need a marker and therefore is in
conflict with policy cs0 to development
in the countryside and countryside
villages I've not seen any evidence in
the papers of any proven need for
development in this particular location
no public transport transport serves to
the site any future residents would
broad purposes be dependent on the use
of private cars to access local
facilities such as the doctor surgery
which is located at the southern end of
Needham Market this complex of the aims
of the national planning and policy
framework to aspire to a low-carbon
economy and also policies see s03
reduced contributions deployment change
flooding issues I know the area quite
well and the site is on a slope with a
drainage ditch running across it the
adjacent land falling within flood zones
two and three the runoff from
development on this site can only make
matters worse
these Suffolk England drainage board
have commented in their consultation
response on pace when I
25 fourth paragraph last sentence prior
to engagement with the consenting
process no assurance can be provided by
the board that the wider drainage
network has sufficient capacity to
accept the proposed positive discharge
connection over development whilst I
appreciate this is an outline planning
application the indicative estate style
layout shown on page 144 incorporated a
considerable proportion of three and
four-bedroom houses would be out of
keeping with the existing residential
properties in the immediate area which
are mainly of single storey bungalow
type configuration this is in conflict
with policy age 13 design and layout of
housing development and policy age 15
development to reflect a local
characteristics for these reasons I
cannot support this application thank
you thank you Cathy Phillips
thank you Jim on top of what my
colleague has already said the flood
management report only arrived this
morning and we haven't had time to
really talk about this and it was sent
on the where is it the 15th of July why
is it taking so long to arrive you know
we should get these papers earlier yeah
it was just I noticed this morning in
the bundle that the incorrect response
had been provided to you in the bundle I
want to make sure that we had the
correct response I think on page under
25 for the report I know that they've
removed they're holding objection but
then when we go to the bundle the
Holding objections still in place I
wanted to make sure that we had the most
up-to-date comments from them from the
15th of July and to make sure that
members were in full receive the the
opinions of the flood and water
management team gave it given that the
flood zone on the site yes it would have
been nice
although the
the field is not actually in a
floodplain itself is between two
floodplains and as Michael stated is on
a slope and therefore any runoff is
going to go the the actual building is
down slope of the the flood ditch so
therefore all the runoff is going to run
straight down towards the river and
across the road and and flood the areas
are already in danger of flooding the
doctor's surgery need the market is
struggling to cope at the moment and
although they may say otherwise there
that will take up to two weeks to get an
appointment there unless you're very
fortunate and therefore this would put a
lot more pressure on them and it's also
outside the settlement boundary which I
see is against our own ruling thank you
are there any questions for the ward
members councillor Mansell please thank
you I have a number of questions that
come to me during the people being able
to speak I think some of them may be for
the planning officer which are and also
try and go through which ones they are
I'd like to ask the ward members about
the schooling of people increasing some
Mary do you know I mean dewd children go
to debenhams or stay market or stops in
high school do most of the children go
to creatives Mary primary or do they go
to need a market and it's there a
pedestrian path all the way to creating
some very primary school those are my
questions that I think the ward members
may be best placed to answer and my
question to the planning officer is
about the dent proposed density of
housing whilst I know this is an outline
Planning Commission we've got to fit a
load of houses onto a plot of land and
I'd like to know what the density is
excluding the flood area which isn't
going to be built on so although it may
look like a big
a nice open development a lot of it is
in flood zone so if the Planning Office
is able to produce that for me and how
that compares with the existing housing
density in the area thank you so we'll
then we'll have the officer answer first
and then we'll come to the ward members
yeah so if we look at density the
application site itself with 4312 eggs
including all of it results in a density
of $18 per hectare if we take out the
flood zone and the meadow beyond that
increases the density to 27 when we look
a really across to the development and
Margaret screen appears
look comparing and contrasting that the
industry of layout with the layout of
dwellings there it appears that visually
it looks to be a similar density but
actually when you look at the at the
site area for this and Margaret's green
development its density is reduced to
around 12 per hectare so there's a there
would be a jump of six I mean looking at
the entire site and then a larger jump
if we exclude the flood zone and meadow
beyond thank you and moving to the ward
members to answer the three questions
please I'm afraid I don't know the
answer regarding the school and as
regards the continuous footpath I'm
quite convinced that it is not
continuous in some places so it does
been walking in a road
Stephen any points and yeah the I
believe they go to step up and and that
is the prescribed catchment area for
that area now for the buses although
there are earlier generations that go to
stone knocking hi other than that it's
much nicer thank you and councillor
Matheson thank you yeah on page one to
seven the highways look at residual
cumulative impacts on the road network
and I was thinking about that and I do
live in need and market so I'm a bit
familiar with with that but is is the
main access to to need them for vehicles
under the under the bridge in whatever
the roads call we can't think of it is
that the way through because only that
is effectively an alternative single
direction Road no it isn't actually the
normal route would be via Hawks Mill
Street and round in that direction
rather than down cauldron burrowed under
the Reeves restricted railway bridge
although down Hawks Mill Street there is
also another railway bridge just for
clarity on that there Hawks mill if I
remember properly you go into that
bridge do you not there's no restriction
yeah there's no restriction okay any
other questions so Steve just reply to
that and there is also a restriction
that there is no footpath underneath the
bridge either thank you any other
questions for the ward members thank you
yep thank you yeah so there is a height
restriction going under the railway
bridge and obviously you've got the
smaller bridge as you arrive at orcs
mill and obviously for those who are
familiar with the locality there's a
footpath connection into I can't recover
through its Crown Street in Needham
which it comes off the corner where
autocar farm Junction is so that
directly provides connectivity into the
centre avoiding the necessity of
navigating a couple of bridges and
traffic associated with it like Jim
[Music]
thank you sir we're now moving to debate
who'd like to start
anyone saw nominate
rare isn't it okay counselor Manson in
the absence of anybody else I don't I
don't really want to be the first person
to speak on every application although
this doesn't seem a particularly popular
development I have less reservations
than I did about the previous one about
its sustainability it is within a mile
of needham market it is within a mile of
creating some very primary school and
although the ward members seem to have
some doubt about the footpath to
creating some very primary school it
does look as if there is one on Google
Street View I just wanted their
confirmation because it looks like it's
got a path that sort of goes up the bank
of the road so I think that you know
there is and the and the county highway
their County infrastructure people do
say that there is a safe walking route
to the catchment Scorch I'm assuming is
creating some memory now there isn't a
public there isn't a pavement under the
bridge in turn either market if people
are going to get into the shops in the
town but as we've said and also on the
map you can see there is that footpath
that cuts along the valley so there is
Podesta safe pedestrian access to the
amenities of need and market and to the
primary school leader market does have a
range of shops public transport station
all the rest of it and they and they are
within walking distance and I know much
as I despise the use of the motor car
for everything I know most people don't
share my views but it is theoretically
feasible I think to walk a mile to the
coop should be within the scope of most
people we just need to educate them
better
the and I wasn't a previous DCP I think
there was another application in this in
this close by just down the road and
I've looked I think that was 450 odd or
something so there and that that seemed
to be passed by the committee
now I realize that there may be some
cumulative impact here because there's
another development of a similar sort of
size but I really I don't think we have
any grounds really for refusing this
application I think it is a sustainable
location in as much as it's probably one
of you know an acceptable terms of
sustainability new residents will be
able to walk and I have seen people
walking on those paths and to need to
market from creating so I really you
know I think there are so few grounds
for anything but approval here but I'd
like to hear what other people have got
to say thank you
anybody else Casa Brewster thank you
aiming excuse me sorry and yeah I've
just been looking at the the consul T
comments from the parish council there
there are only really four bullet points
one mentions the overdevelopment of
critics and Mary which is debate all
because obviously the a14 is very very
close to this and so hence greetings
that Mary is within the a14 and rail
corridor which has been recognized for
development through the mid Suffolk area
and the second one is over sub sorry
this is on page one four five over
subscribed school and struggling doctor
surgery need a market and we've heard
that actually there's no room for
expansion on on either of those having
said that co-payments can do quite a lot
of stuff to mitigate those those
problems the power cables you've
answered that one
current flooding issues was the fourth
one and looking at the papers which I
know we haven't had that much time to
read through but they do look to be some
conditions there which would I believe
take care of those issues so rather like
canceling they install III I don't have
too much problem with this one and and
feel that you know it is possible and
and probably again difficult to find
reasonable planning reasons to refuse it
Thank You counselor having him yes I
agree with everything counselor brewster
and councillor Mansell said I think
Jason's guilt anism
there's Atmos covered everything with
the conditions he suggested and I'm not
happy to him recommend approval on this
I'll go second again mr. chairman yeah I
I mean I do I do share the view that
there were there are not reasons to
refuse this I do think that there's
there should have been more concern
regarding the Hulk's Mill Street vehicle
bottleneck as it as it is already
but given we haven't got highways
support on the point I think that would
weird you know we'd be forced to try and
use it to refuse anyway so I shall be
approving relaxedly but if we are going
that way then I have some some
particular point somewhere on what
conditions what else we might say on the
conditions can I spray onto that now
please do yes I think I think that oh
there to ask a question of the war
members is this turn and actually float
sloping southwards broadly
you sang it sloped bring him mr.
Isabelle to sentence then if you can get
the planner I think my recollection
having driven past this site on many
journeys to work the slope of n does
effectively go from the you can get the
get of site plan back map Daniel go from
the eastern side roughly in a
northwesterly direction on that plan it
would be hard to actually say absolutely
but you do slope down to the water
course and you've got an over breach to
the south side at the cluster of trees
in the corner so you know you've got
that that raised land there but the land
itself is is is generally sloping in
that direction and doubtless that was
the walk member will correct my memory
any comments sorry for clarity no it
slopes down from the east to the west to
the to the water course from my
recollection of passing the site and
slightly from the north east as well so
that you've got the a14 corridor and you
know there's always been some ground
modeling around the over bridge to the
south but that doesn't affect this land
so generally speaking everything is
running in that sort of northeastly sort
of southwesterly direction but obviously
as a cross gradient going from the east
to the west and at that point I really
would defer to local knowledge because
it is some time since I traveled there
we were getting a nod from the ward
members so let's let's establish this
float it's actually going away from the
development to the stream that's sort of
direction yeah yeah the the point I was
looking for this for whether we should
be writing one of mr. Isabel's famous
informative
suggesting that the the developer when
they go to reserve matters does have a
look at em PPF 140 150 about using the
land appropriately for energy efficiency
purposes so as reasonable Jim does say
and reason also that effectively you're
talking about orientation on you're
making the most of the of the alignment
of the development with what comes
forward so yes we will take that away as
an informative chairman quite happy to
do
if proposal and second about having
thank you approach the secondary yeah
well good thank you okay so we have
proposer we have a seconder for moving
to approval with the recommendation with
that informative notice all those in
favor
unanimous approved we're now going to
take because we're all of an age a
10-minute break so if you be back in
here please for 11:35
you
everybody that cysts back in the room
we're now going to move on to agenda
item 7c which is in the world of stolen
mrs. outline planning permission with
some matters reserved the erection of 34
dwellings associated garage in parking
and as detailed in your sheets Daniel
thank you chair yes this is an outline
application for 34 drawings in Astana
basketball different from the last item
we're all matters were reserved some
matters are submitted for approval at
this stage that includes access and
layout we go through and going this is
the site outlined in purple it lies
between East End Road which runs along
here and then you've got the a 1120
tourist routes going on this way in
front of Stanton Barnes
the site still outlined in purple we've
got a number of greatly listed buildings
within the area we've got this one to
the south which is the school farmhouse
we've got this one to the west which is
the old schoolhouse and then we've got
long and tall up here to the north the
brown line is the sustainable
conservation area and the edge here is
the area of the site you could see that
we've got some sporadic development to
the west into the north around East End
Road and we've got stunning barns
complex to the south and then if we come
slightly further out we've got the edge
of the stone impossible along here at
the junction of the road become slightly
further out you get an idea of the
character of stone the muscle itself
it's fairly linear running along the
street the o1 1120 although there are a
few instances of small cul-de-sac
development off the street as well
here's the hose layout this is revision
F we've gone through a few with the
applicant they've been helpful in
providing additional drawings this
provides a density of 17 runnings per
hectare we've got a call they suck
arranged around a single access will
come forward we've got revision G as
well this follows on from comments made
by the Highways Authority regarding this
section of private drive to serve these
dwellings there was a fear looking at
the last application that there would be
some issues in terms of headlights
dazzling drivers between the 11
in this private access Drive so this has
just been submitted to to mitigate that
and we could implement some landscaping
to further mitigate along the front
here's a slightly further removed it
shorts of visibility displays to the
site because obviously access would be
agreed at this point and that would not
be moved on submission of reserved
matters and then we've got a plan
provided by the finder by the applicants
but noting that we've got a small
development here granted permission in
2016 for twenty ten units we've got the
edge of Astana mass ball here and from
the site here we've got a provision of a
footpath along this section of the 11:20
which currently has none there's also
section 106 funding available to County
Council's as far away the authority to
connect a footpath from the edge of this
development where it joins the road and
then along the frontage of this demand
in the stomach Barnes which is yet to be
implemented the development site itself
here would provide some form of frontage
footpath as well but they'd also be
footpaths running down through the site
from East End Road so you'd be able to
get from the site back into ston mass
born from stannum a school just onon
Barnes and then also from East End Road
down to some buns
and then into stottlemyre itself so
gaining a number of connectivity
improvements through the development
we'll also be provided with 3d modeling
we've got a fairly uniform two-story
development is noted in the report that
obviously in terms of design we'd
probably be looking to see some
amendment to this reserved matters such
as we've got a little bit of variation
Andrew fights and we've got something
that's a little bit less uniform and
maybe speaks a little bit more to a few
different character areas if we come now
to site photos this is the site this is
taken from east down the road looking
south over the site it's an existing
agricultural field this is the boundary
of the site with a low-lying hedgerow
and then we've also got some quite good
landscape screening too long and tall
beyond and this is looking the other
direction this is looking east long East
End Road and that screen and continues
along here and if we come to the top of
East End Road and look back down we have
that continuing along there as well this
is an aerial view a more recent aerial
through 2019 the images I've just shown
you a dated 2009 but we can see that
from the area there is still a good
amount of tree cover and landscaping to
that boundary maintained and also to
Heather these as well which is this
property here this is looking along the
11:20 at the edge of the site this is or
at the where the edge and we're going
back into style there are few trees are
on the boundary but there are
significant areas of open space through
which units the access could be taken
and then here we are at the entrance
autonomous but as well you can see the
30 mile an hour limit Forster on
impossible starts at the closest edge of
the site to stone a masked ball I think
it's proposed within the application to
remove the 30 mile an hour speed limit
so that it comes further out along the
o1 11:28 1120
to come back to the layouts and the
aerial views
it's go ahead
yes so in terms of the application it's
been sow in the report that office
recommends approval for the science
subject to confirmation from highway
said that sufficiently satisfied by the
amendment to the wrong way sorry to this
plan to see that there lay comments are
sufficiently and dealt with in addressed
prior to receiving those late comments
we had reports from the high res
authority that they were happy with the
previous revisions to revision F well
they then identified those those issues
and have suggested conditions so those
have been carried forward but we just
want confirmation and there's nothing
more
they require we'd also require a
completion of a section 106 agreement
being offered a policy compliant level
affordable housing on-site and there's
also this linear run of open space along
the top of the site as well so we're
getting some connectivity along here
obviously just to maintain make sure
that we've got public access secured at
all times and that the maintenance of
the site is secured as well I'll pass
the item back to members to take initial
questions just for having him thank you
um you said a lot about on footways but
I just one of the things that the
highways asked her was that um to
confirm the foot way within the crow
field road application can be used by
the public yeah so going back in
speaking to the agent and he's the agent
for that site as well yeah so it will be
the intention is to provide a public
footpath not just a footpath for the
users of the crow field road sign but a
footpath connection through to Istanbul
and then along to strongarm system close
to the Munsell thank you I too was going
to ask about that point that counsel had
him mentioned but I'm not familiar with
Astana basketball and I don't know where
the crow Field Road application is
so could somebody point that out to me
and the other question I was going to
ask was on page 183 in the Andean water
respond our consultation responds it
says that the local planning authority
should seek the advice of the local
flood authority or internal drainage
board and I wondered whether that had
been done because I can't see a comment
from either of those two bodies the site
we're considering today here then this
is the crow field Road site and this and
this is crow field road itself here so
in Stoneham a spot itself there's
existing footpath to the edge of the
sadhana Muspel that see site and then
there's no footpath beyond this point so
anyone from sunrise but wanting to
access it on and Barnes walks along the
edge of the a1 1120 there are verges but
they aren't particularly large and they
are particularly they're maintained and
you know public public convenience so
they aren't necessary it's not
necessarily a a welcoming route but it
is route that people do take so it's
part of this application within the
bounds of this application there's a
footpath shown down this side here so
you would come to the core on a cross
flow field Road and to this site then
there's a section 106 contribution
that's of a car which would be utilizing
to provide an element of footpath along
to the edge of the stone and bond site
and then this application obviously
would be connecting up to that on the
other side so it'd still be a need to
cross the a1 1120 but obviously 30 mile
an hour speed limit has moved up there
is an increase in pedestrian safety and
making that crossing
so with regards to - sorry before we go
on council months or do you want to come
back on that my apologies
yes sorry I haven't had the response
about the the drainage and can cannot is
the planning officer able to say whether
that public that footpath within the
Kofu Road application it's likely to be
adopted as a public driveway
I can't speak for the Highways Authority
as to whether they'd want to adopt that
as probably right I think that would
probably be off it is permissive path
rather than a public right-of-way with
regard to draining Java C consultation
with the internal drainage board we
haven't taken consultation from them
besides flood zone one we've not noted
any particular assets that they need to
be consulted on we could reconstruct on
that if that would satisfy members but
in terms of consultation with the IDB
that is generally a separate
consultation anyway they would need you
know you would normally game client
promotion you might consult them at the
same time but normally in terms of
speaking to the ITB or the Environment
Agency depending on who looks after
connections into inter drainage ditches
that's normally a separate process so we
don't necessarily need to have that
comments at this point
Kousaka thank you I'd be grateful for
some help in result understanding the
tension between the recommendation to
approve and the comments of the
assessment planning policy team
that was it now I had it a moment ago
and I made the mistake of turning the
page 186 yeah bottom of eight one eight
six top of one eight seven six in terms
of the playing policy response obviously
as officers we've had to weigh the
material weight given to the adopted
local plan so in part that comes from
judging against the policy for the MPP F
to see where we have policies that can
form with the directives of the MPP -
where we don't where policies don't then
afford to the lesser weight we're also
obviously need to bear in mind that we
are in a position where we have an
adopted development plan that is not
wholly compliant with the MPP F and we
have the joint Local Plan that's
currently emerging but isn't
sufficiently advanced enough to be given
sort of a a moderate degree of material
way within decisions so in terms of
weighing the application it's out in
section 3 of the report we've gone
through and made the assessments with
regards to see s1 c s2 and the MPP F and
have come to a different decision than
our colleagues in planning policy but
this is the application as as we have it
before us and you know we're weighing it
against the development plan and wait we
can attach them to another plan that we
currently feel we're able to reasonably
demonstrate just so we're clear about
that point about the emerging plan LED
approach which is described by policy
team the advice of Robert Hobbs has
previously been that at this point in
time given the consultation ongoing with
that document that document has very
limited weight that weight will grow but
at this point in time it does not
withstanding that you've got a suite of
existing policies to weigh and that
question of conformity with the
PPF is is a matter of partly your
judgment and doubt as we might get into
that conversation during debate
I believe it's counselor Baxter Brewster
and then counselor padding it Thank You
mr. chair
and yeah can we I'm just going back to
footpaths and actually 30 mile an hour
limits can we just have a little clarity
on that because I know there's two or
three different developments going on
there who was actually providing both of
those is that possible so yeah so within
this this application of reviving the
footpaths within it within its site are
shown in the layout and the 30 mile
another movement would be funded by this
development in terms of the connection
along here there is section 106
contributions for Suffolk County Council
to implement a footpath along part of
this run and then this application here
and the developer of which which is a
separate developer would be providing a
footpath link to connect to the edge of
Suffolk highways footpaths
delivered through the section 106
through that site and then there would
be a crossing a crow field road to
connect up to the existing footpath
network so it's basically August a team
if every okay so we've got at the moment
30 mile an hour limits around here we've
obviously got the access into the site
around here and then you know the this
this portion of the a 111 20 is a
unrestricted speed limit national speed
limit in part of achieving visibilities
flows and allowing for a more controlled
access to this site movement of that 30
mile an hour speed limit to the edge of
this site will be provided so you'd have
slower moving traffic coming along the
frontage of the site you'd have the
access making connection
if that slow-moving traffic and then if
you were to have pedestrians making
access to Astana and Barnes or from this
sign across into Stein as well you would
have them making any crossings on a road
with a much lower speed limit than
currently exists at the moment same
alanines but and now high speed limit is
here the access to Stone Barns is
further up and from that point on
pedestrians journey you're coming
against traffic moving at internal
speeds server critters come back mr.
chairman it is there any opportunity
because I there's a relatively short
distance across the frontage of that
site of it to the access point I'm just
wondering if there is any opportunity
whatsoever just that much further
I know 30 more limits are 30 more limits
but often often drivers don't slow down
potentially and we can explore that
point with highways when they come back
to confirm about the changes to the
there I don't think that's unreasonable
at all I think that in in part movement
of the 30 mile an hour speed limit is
accepted by the agent and the applicant
and in highways as well I think they're
keen to see that moved as well thank you
if I can just pick up on that I mean the
the process of traffic regulation is
somebody to be separate all making
mechanism there would be a consultation
process so we're not completely in
control of that and and arguably I
believe the a custom is to have the
signs where the regulation or the starts
rather than be ambitious and go further
beyond that but I understand what you're
saying would take that one tell so
having him okay Elsa Madison thank you
yeah yeah to two questions
um paragraph 3.6 page 189
you you mentioned the the settlement
hierarchy it doesn't actually set what
was the position of this village in the
settlement hierarchy
from memory I think it's a primary
village although I think is reduce down
although I'm happy to be corrected as we
flip through the relevant document it's
not one where it will get answer P which
is checking policy oh sorry that's
secondary right
secondary okay second question yet you
on page 191 a la 6.1 you you've you said
there is a close physical relationship
with neighboring domestic development
Stalin balancing isn't residential part
of managers house so I was I was
wondering quite what what the that
phrase was intended to mean because
certainly you know Stalin ballsy's is
notoriously not supposed to be because
he don't sure no yeah it's definitely
not a stone the bonds in any way shape
or form in terms of the MVP ethic sets
out a specific test at paragraph 79 to
avoid isolation isolated dwellings in
the countryside in terms of the
interpretation of that policy legal
judgments have come down from neighbor
and districts that say that isolation is
to be interpreted as physical isolation
only so in terms of that paragraph and
apologies I don't make it clear within
the report I should have done we have a
number of domestic developments across
to the north of East End Road we've got
long haul we've got a number of sort of
sporadic de Valence there and then to
the west as well so in terms of domestic
dwellings that's what I'm referencing
and then obviously I think looking
towards stolen bonds to the south
obviously there's an accomplishment
there were a number of facilities
provided on stone and barns in terms of
post office shops things like that that
could be made you sort of barring
Einstein poverty not including yet Oh
Samantha thank you for allowing me to
come back some of these recent questions
have have caused some confusion in my
mind I'm afraid on page 193 of our
papers it talks about the stolen bonds
planning permission including a traffic
regulation order results in a change of
location of a 30 mile an hour speed
limit was the previous question
referring to the newly proposed 30 mile
an hour speed limit from this on bonds
application or the existing 30 mile an
hour speed limit and if so could we have
some clarity as to where those are and
will be and also on page 183 in the
response from stolen basketball Parrish
Clark it says that the astronomer sport
is classified as the secondary village
in the current local plan I've just
looked at the draft joint Local Plan and
solar mass board seems to have been
upgraded to a core village yeah no so in
the in the current development plans on
moshpit as a secondary village within
the emergent joint Local Plan I'll have
to take your word for it I don't have it
I don't have it in front of me but yeah
if it's a core village then that would
be its new designation in terms of the
joint local plan though we are very
early in the process of consultations
that may be subject to change yes sir
just while we're on that one obviously
we're dealing what is today what
policies in today so we all get clarity
but actually it's what is today okay
that's the bit that matters what
policies are in place right now that
affect this development in in terms in
terms of the 30 mile an hour limits and
I think as part of the section 106 from
the 2015 development that's done at
Barnes which is in part funding
provision of the foot way along that
side of the a11 and 20 there's also a TR
o require to move
speed limit so we'd be moving it along
further out yes if we can go I've just
well you're getting them up I'm sure
we'll become a core village but as I
just said yeah it's a separate village
right now that's what we're gonna
discuss so we've got a public
right-of-way or a footpath to be enacted
here and I would assume that the TR rose
to move the 30 mile an hour speed limit
up to the edge of that foot path with
that and further movement out to the
edge of this site at some point where is
the existing 30 mile an hour limit
existing 30 mile an hour limit is on the
edge of Astana masterball here there's
part of the TR o for this Donna Barnes
application which is also providing part
of the foot way that will move out and
will join up with the edge of the foot
way is to be provided and there's part
of this application I suspect there's
gonna be further movement along to the
edge because we're having it thank you
I'm gonna ask you hope you haven't
already mentioned it but I know their
board members here what is there how
many bus services - this is the village
M so in terms of in terms of access
we've got that outlined no we don't in
terms of access that's outlined in in
Section six are you confused myself my
own numbering between the two reports so
there is some bus connection with in
Stoneham as well I think there were two
I think one outside the village hall and
one at the corner of Croft Road in terms
of bus services we've got the 1 1 5
operating there connects for Amanda trim
to equip switch and I don't know if the
I don't know the frequency Castle Norris
thank you about my questions just been
answered actually in the officers
response to council had a girl's
question thank you
that's a war boys just so good
the
long-lens house which is at the top of
the context of great tool listed
building it's a large house set back
from East End Road the heritage team
proposes that the layout submitted
proposals to retain and then build
buffer area along the northern boundary
which would greatly reduce the impact to
the built environment is that part of
reserved matters so in terms of the
reserve matters we've got the layout to
agree at this point so if we agree the
layout that will be fixed in place what
may be subject to change is the
landscaping within that buffer because
landscaping would still be a reserved
matter but that would be landscaping to
the edges of the site as well and to the
frontage so we'd have some clay in terms
of the appearance of that buffer and
what's provided within it in terms of
landscaping conditions but by securing
the layout at this stage we are securing
that buffer to to the to the listed
building now thank you
there any final questions excellent okay
so we do have some speakers so
straightaway we'll have the parish
council she's mr. Ian Wright please and
again as before you have three minutes
no reminders to get closer to the time
thank you guys
parish council unanimously agreed to
object to this planning application on
the grounds of the strength of public
opinion against the development locally
the scale of development the impact on
abilities as a whole the ability of the
diverse social infrastructure in you
peel the utilities to cope with
additional households safety of access
to the site impact on the setting of
listed buildings impact on the character
of Eastern Road and the suitability of
using Assizes classifieds open country
type of residential development the
Raposo conflicts with MS DC's current
and proposed local plans and policies
which obviously have validity under NPP
F now the MSD seeking house of 5-year
housing on supply the site is well
outside both the existing and the draft
local plan settlement boundaries
the parish council is not alone in
subjection your own senior policy
strategic strategy manager who I think
this opinion should be respected
strongly recommends refusal of this
application and their objections point
to the proposal speculative nature
undermined the emerging plan led
approached it being out of keeping in
proportion with the existing settlement
and surrounding area and its impact on
the infrastructure such as schools
health and highways I mean still
payments can help but they don't buy off
objections the County Council's
strategically armed officers submission
also echoes those points and we fail to
understand why the planning officers so
casually dismissed these opinions both
the joint local town and MSD sees own
planning policies should have some
respect the site's never been identified
on Sheila's a debt as a potential
residential site and therefore must be
considered speculative alternative sites
in and around the village have been
identified and assessed in drawing at
the journal medical plan and there is
another application for 46 houses
located within the village those coming
before these committee shortly also
mister currents are fortunately missing
for about the highways actions highways
are reducing the speed limit to 50 miles
per hour not 30 and I've made that
submission to central government and the
stolen bonds footpath that's mentioned
is entirely speculative I haven't got
time to go into it now but I have to
answer questions about it but it
couldn't be interested couldn't be
delivered without to come support to
purchase orders and other issues so
happy and some question about later view
issue I must warn you that approving
this application would create a
significant precedent that developers
were quite sensibly quite rightly used
to justify each and every speculative
greenfield development in this borough
if you approve it so in summary star
Marcela Paris canceled like your own
strategic planning team and Suffolk
County's strategic planning team as the
committee to refuse the application on
the grounds of conflict with MS DC's
current and proposed local plan and
policies is disproportionate nature to
the existing settlement and our
suitability the location and its lack of
sustainability Thank You Brenda Tommy we
questions please about four kalsa having
do you know about the bus service the
bus service as I think mr. Cameron said
there is a bus there's a bus stop at
domes field which is fairly close to the
proposed development and warm right at
the other end of the village they are
limited to peak times very limited and
they are also both bus services are
under threat from Galloway's calling
them in there to the named roofs of
their calling in next year though it's
more than one that day I think there is
one that gets you in purple one bit hey
John the detail one gets you in about
half past seven and the return buses are
I think ones at half-past four and once
a night half past six but I'm willing to
be challenged on both of those points
I'm just a point on that obviously we
can't suppose what's going to happen
with a bus service we will deal with
what is today so another question them
from councillor Brewster Thank You
chairman and yeah can you just enlarge
on what your comments on the footpath
yes sir to bring up the the plans I can
explain that right it's like a closed
one if you could please Daniel sorry
that's too close okay back back to where
you were the the footpath across the
frontage of stolen bonds is obviously
within the gift of stolen bonds and
these part of their section 106 of your
card pointed out well you can't see very
clearly on that map you can see it a
green area with some trees a building in
it between that and the next development
along to the left the the verge
alongside that that property which is a
private property is about 18 inches so
there's no wake up of the footpath down
there without compulsory purchasing the
garden of the house or narrowing de 1120
and the conversation with Highways they
say that's not what happened there is
also you never have to cross the road
the footpath through the village is not
continuous or enough that you'd have to
cross the road to get the cross to make
it continuous there is another property
which is
by a local charity which I'm a trustee
which also is very close to the verge
and you'd have to compulsory purchase
that from the charity to put it on that
side of the road and the development
just to the left of where the cursor is
now is only as outlined plan information
the owner is disputing the access
through that development and I think I'm
right saying it's the fourth year of its
outline plan commission so if that's
ever going to developed your guess is as
good as mine but to say that that
footpath is deliverable I think it's a
little bit iffy other than the bit
across the front of the disconnected bit
across the front of Stalin bars itself
any other questions
oh sorry it's just and also the speed
limit is gonna be 50 miles an hour not
30 so you're gonna have to walk along
the verge alongside a fairly quick road
doctor third time out already okay
obviously that's to be deemed factual so
we can only go up what we've got here
but your point is made any other
questions
yeah Celso having thank you would it be
unfeasible to walk along I think it was
called East End Road at the back of the
development and then it along the road
there I think it would but there is
still the footpath still doesn't connect
beyond the aged's village and it is fact
on the other side of the road at that
point possible okay thank you thank you
for your time thank you we do have an
object which is Peter Anderson please
so again you have three minutes yes
Thank You chair object to this proposal
on the following grounds the location
from a case officers presentation you
will have seen the site is completely
isolated from the village and over two
hundred meters from the settlement
boundary this proposal is contrary to
myth suffers current and emerging local
plans the case officers report and
conclusions unfortunately cannot be
viewed as an accurate representation as
elements are either misleading or
factually incorrect I'm happy to expand
at a later point speed limit will be
amended to fifty miles an hour and not
thirty as explained the proposed site is
unsustainable the site cannot be
connected to the village by the foot by
foot path as previously explained
therefore car dependency will be
excessive a 'td completely odds with the
MPP F and to put in a state this estate
of thirty four houses into context it is
individual properties that surround the
proposed site the intrusive effect of a
housing estate will be huge on the
countryside and the surrounding
residence footpath access to the village
as you've just heard in a recent meeting
with Suffolk highways that I attended it
was stated the only alternative to
constructing a footpath between the
proposed site and the village was to
either narrow the main road or to
compulsory purchase land owned by
residents along the route as the verges
owned by highways were too narrow to
build a safe footpath the highways
representative confirmed at that point
that neither option would likely be
considered therefore this proposal will
continue to be disconnected from the
village and would be unsustainable move
on to mid Suffolk strategy plan the
department your own strategy planning
department report strongly recommends
refused of the proposal states that the
proposal in question appears very
speculative out of keeping it's very
insular as a proposal is
disproportionate to the area's character
Astana massive is primarily a linear
pattern of development along the a 1120
nada village of housing estates and the
proposal would undermine the emerging
laid plan approach the known geography
and the context of the area and they
summarized by state
in the proposal does not constitute
sustainable development and they
strongly recommend refusal the future
impact as a local resident I know with
certainty and I can support it but
should this application succeed
landowners in the immediate vicinity of
this site will apply for residential
planning permission citing this
application as precedent
so if grantee this will create an
opportunity for dozens if not hundreds
of residential units built in open
countryside affecting the areas and
impacting massively across meet suffer
so in summary I would urge the committee
to support mid suffers current and
emerging local plans and refuses
application thank you thank you
must been practicing that's good any
questions please no thank you yeah thank
you
we're now hear from the agents mr. Craig
Beach and please
this proposal is for 34 new low-energy
dwellings on a parcel of land opposite
Stoneham barns enclosed on three sides
by highways and existing residential
development the site is well contained
there an outline application it is
envisaged that 14 of these dwellings
will be much needed to in three-bedroom
homes with 16 house proposed as
four-bedroom Wellings the design
features a community park and large
landscaped open space to the northern
boundary incorporating a rainwater pond
houses are orientated to face the street
or overlook public open space with car
parking garages hidden to the rear
ensuring an attractive street scene the
officers report notes its potential to
create good townscape and the layout as
being acceptable a wide planted green
buffer of native species hedges and
trees will be bound to the eastern edge
to open fields with extensive tree
planting and hedge planting proposed
across the site at present there are no
trees or hedgerows and the extensive
landscape was significantly enhanced the
development opposite the site is Donna
Barnes leisure and shopping village with
post-office sharps recreational
facilities restaurant and 34 other
registered businesses a pavement is
included which will connect the
development to stone a village with its
school and further facilities and sauna
Barnes opposite the site is on a bus
route with a regular two hourly service
and its proposed to extend the 30 mile
per hour limit to cover the site
entrance the application provides
much-needed affordable housing in full
compliance and support of the council's
policy the applicant a lifelong British
resident feels a responsibility to
provide an appropriate and attractive
development that offers wider community
benefits were ever possible as stated by
your planning officer this is a
sustainable location with good
pedestrian connectivity and no adverse
impact on the natural environment or
biodiversity we urge you to follow your
playing officers recommendation for
approval
thank you thank you do you have any
questions for the agent
thank you sir
the world members not here which
councillor Susie morally but if you
could read out the email that we had
from it that represents their thoughts
and views on this proposal
Stoneham a school has in the region of
240 homes this development together with
others already approved but not yet
built would increase the village by
about twenty three percent
why has this application come to
committee when so many consul T
responses are missing the footpath that
was supposed to have been delivered as
part of the stolen barns application
reference 30 150 / 15 is not deliverable
as the proposed route is over private
land and is supposed to join up with the
footpath of subject to the Craig Hill
Road application of 48 to 47 / 16 this
is also on private land and cannot be
accessed by the general public so is
this is also not deliverable if this
application is approved it will mean
that children will have to access the
main a 11 20 where lorries are
travelling at speeds of 60 miles an hour
to get to the other side of the main
road walk down the a 1120 and then cross
back over to access the school this
planning application originally came off
a pre-op advice at a time when mid
suffer did not have a five-year lands
implied now now that we do have a
provable five-year land supply we do not
need to approve applications that are
planning policy team are wrecking
recommending for refusal with regards to
MSD C planning policy I don't want to
repeat everything that you have already
heard in the report but would ask that
you consider the details as set out at
the bottom of page 186 and the top of
187 this application flies in the face
of a mode of our emerging plan led
approach and totally undermines
everything that our MSD C planning
policy team are trying to do with our
joint local plan and putting our
communities at the heart of determining
what is best for the VIPs for their
village
also on page 190 it is stated that
occupiers of the development will use
local services and facilities installing
a school and at Stone Barns
there are no formal facilities within
ston am a school other than the school
and the mail order Mexican shock ston
amount stolen bonds is a private site
and has an enforcement notice
outstanding for non-compliance the owner
of saman barns has already banned
several people from the village which is
perfectly within his rights but you
cannot on the one hand argue that it is
a private site and at the same time
state that it that it has public
services village does not support this
application I do not support this
application and our endless DC policy
planning team do not support this
application I ask that the committee
does not support this application thank
you Robert I'm just a point on the
enforcement of Donna Barnes as it's been
just read out that it's got nothing to
do with this application therefore
please dismiss that and let's look at
this for its merits what's written in
front of this council Mansell sorry I
haven't I have another question before
we get to debate and I related to the
officer saying at the beginning of his
presentation but this was an outlined
planning permission with layout as per
the plans so can I just have some
clarity that that I noticed on the plan
there is like rear court parking it was
actually the the applicants comments
made me look at it again and I noticed
that the design out crime officer
whatever the terminology is have made no
comment and yet we do have comments
about rear court parking that isn't
overlooked another application so I just
wanted what the planning officer had to
say about his views on record parking
yeah so the layout is to be agreed at
this stage so we would be securing the
rear court parking I think that
obviously we don't have the response of
designer crime
so before us today and I think partly
that stems from the similar comments we
raised on the last item about not being
able to force up our console T's to
respond where they haven't despite how
many times we might chase them in terms
of rear court parking I think that it
can be an effective solution to ensuring
that you don't end up with a street
scene dominated by cars and I think that
often in terms of designing a scheme
you're often trying to balance differing
objectives while the you know designing
out crime officer for the police will
want to avoid streets connecting up to
two other streets to provide through
routes we don't have that but then at
the same time we do have some real
parking courts but then they are quite
an efficient way of providing an amount
of parking and provided you've got some
natural surveillance over those and
there's nothing to say that we wouldn't
we do have you know front gardens and
Andrea Gardens facing and overlooking
them then you can eliminate an element
of undesirable behavior that might take
place inside those locations cosa having
okay thank you
I'm throwing out questions I know the
ward numbers not here we will move
swiftly to debate Telstar having and
thank you I'm really I'm torn with this
dilemma because I don't frankly really
like it
I think it's a long way out the village
I think to say that there's some
surrounding development all around it is
stretching the point it says you know a
few houses around it I think that a 120
is a horrible Road it's basically at the
moment with you know it's the road from
the a12 they won4t and it's very busy I
think you know at the moment it's like
can they change it from 50 to 30 will
they move it footpaths are very sort of
shaky if they're going to be able to
connect up to the village I could say
it's a hell of a long walk along you
know I would want to cross that road
twice holding a child's hand frankly
to school and yes sir they're my
thoughts eagle co Samantha
thank you I I too have a lot of concerns
about this application with our current
local plan which is valid solemn a
support is a secondary village this
application is not adjacent to the
existing settlement boundary and yes our
planning officer sale yet surrounded on
three sides by existing development but
as counselor having ever said those are
large properties with large gardens
they're not a modern housing estate and
some of them are old buildings and
there's some listed buildings of
peppering that that surrounding
development that I I also do not
consider this to be a sustainable
location because we've heard about the
issues with the provision of the
footpath that was promised on another
application which I think this
application is really relying on to make
it a walking a possible walking route
into the village and the rest of the
amenities there seem to be some issues
with the speed limit and I am I have my
doubts about the design which we are
being asked to agree at this stage we've
heard our Planning Officers comments on
the rear parking courts and I know I may
not actually agree with the design out
crime responses in a lot of cases but
the reason I don't like rear parking
courts it's nobody uses them they will
park in the highway because they don't
want to walk all the way around from
their rear parking court to their door
and unfortunately that is human nature
so I think we have several reasons that
we could latch on to a refusal on this
case I'm not going to prepare it yet but
I just think it is outside policy it's
not adjacent to the settlement boundary
it's in the countryside it's not
sustainable and I don't think much of
the design I'm happy to wait to hear
what other people have got to say but I
think there's lots of reasons there
thank you come on - on the rural setting
of things and there's a question really
whether this is actually
isolated or not and because in some
people's minds it might seem it is in
other minds it could be attached
thank you yes as Daniel did say earlier
this has been one that brighter district
council had the luxury of taking through
the courts and it's fair to say you have
to be very very remote to be isolated
my advice to committee here today is
that this isn't isolated but you could
certainly make an argument that it's
detached from the main village but I
think you will be on uncertain ground if
you try to argue it's isolation I think
in literal terms there's a there's a
requirement there's an expectation in
paragraph 79 of the npv F that refers to
isolation I think what you mean is is
perhaps something slightly less than
that terminology of isolation because
that really is that would be the the
wiles of somewhere rather than somewhere
which is this sort of removed to its to
a parent settlement so I'd urge a bit of
caution around that word chairman but I
think I understand the principles we're
talking about
thank you that hopefully that will help
you in your silly debate discussion
Council Brewster thank mr. chairman and
[Music]
yes I do have concerns I have to say I
don't feel certain that we can actually
make a fair decision today in terms of
the footpaths structure the speed limit
structure and also another another thing
that's come to my mind
in actual fact that we're expecting
people to cross from this estate into
stone on barns over the a 1120 there is
no way that they can cross safely there
is no crossing proposed or anything like
that personally I don't have too much
problem with the actual estate itself
but I think there are safety issues
which need addressing and I'm just
wondering if we could defer this to to
just see what
and the achieved and I propose that if
that's if I have a second time chairman
it's certainly possible for you to defer
it
there are a suite of issues there that
you've described which you could defer
to seek further information from County
highways colleagues if you so changed
chose those months thank you yeah well
unlike the previous two applications
where I find it reading the papers I
find it quite difficult to see where I
might want to be going with that I
suddenly realized exactly where I wanted
to go with this one and that is that we
should just you on will judge what is in
front of us and what in front of us is
no footways and no speed limit and no
guarantee that those things will appear
they might never be developed so I am
quite clear on that point that we should
be judging it on that basis as far as
the planning policies Conservation's
where objections are concerned at the
I'm been corrected by officers if you
like but it seemed to me that a lot of
what they are saying specifically out of
keeping and also large bulk a mass of
new housing issues on page 186 members
that those are not matters that are
particularly with the cs1 or cs2 and the
rest of the discussions and and reasons
that officers gave earlier when mr.
Gould was questioning the point they are
they are saying some other things apart
from the the oh well is it sustainable
and so forth so like that that point
also and and as members and police other
members here going the same direction
really the nine point one the the you
know surrounding residential development
well no we've established it stolen bars
he's not residential development and
we've also established that the the ones
that the
what's the East End Road was it you know
that's a handful of properties it's not
residential development which was
carries a different different sort of
connotation really and finally again I'm
not comfortable making decisions having
not heard from our landscape or ecology
consult ease all the stuff at work
Wildlife Trust so I'm going to propose
refusal before we go any further with
second is for both proposals actually we
will just hear from mr. Esmond thank
Jamie yes
I mean clearly if that's the route you
go down chairman you will need to set
out your reasoning and identify the
policies and the harms that will be
caused from my perspective I think you
obviously have to look at the layout
that is before you in judging what you
consider to be acceptable you obviously
have some comments from the policy team
which guides you around some of the
issues as they see them but clearly this
question of design and the layout before
you is one that you are entitled to have
regard to the MPP iPhone and that
obviously looks to ensure that good
design is laid in place that improves
the character and quality of an area and
the way it functions and that's indeed a
key aspect of sustainable development I
mean I can talk further about this
chairman but clearly that's an issue
you've got to engage with as members in
coming up with anything and that is a
proposed reason for a few years or I can
talk to you about safe and suitable
access should you so need and whilst
we're discussing this as a point of
principle you will need to and I would
recommend we will ask you to engage with
the question of the impact on listed
buildings because clearly of that is
part of the rationale here and you have
advice from the Heritage Officer so
that's kind of over to committee from
there general well Caleb Brewster
initially proposed for deferment
followed by councillor Matheson
proposing refusal
therefore I need to find a second if
either of those calcium and so I'm happy
to second to councillor Matheson's
proposal for refusal and I'm happy to to
help come up with a list of reasons for
a futile that's good okay so we do have
a proposal a seconder for refusal we're
just gonna have a look at some papers
and then we'll carry on and for my point
of view to be honest here for what it's
worth I'll just find this that the
location of the actual development is
not in keeping with the normal
settlement pattern a pattern and even
though it's not isolated it is outside
of the main village a village with very
little going on in it for the people are
going to live there and also got
concerns over the footpaths and the
legal side of that as well I don't think
I'll ever come forward but that's
speculative yeah the councillor Matheson
you're going to give us a brought at
least a broad indication of the reasons
for refusal yeah yeah well I think if we
really we do we certainly need that
before we move to a vote so I mean would
if the Chairman chairman do you think we
take a few minutes in which we all will
we can sit here do you think or is it
better that we do publicly I think
whatever we do should be public yeah and
you know we're not hiding anything here
so the sub that debate please come up
with some reasons why firm reasons
policy-driven
as to why we're going to refuse this
before we go to the vote cos Madison
well the the the the the usual phrasing
I think pedestrian safety we've we've we
went to town on impressing field on
pedestrian safety admittedly with the
support of highways but you know bearing
in mind all I've said about the fact
that we must look at what's there not
what my turn up in due course
pedestrian safety and then secondly the
the out of keeping design
I'm sure officers can find where that
comes up in policy I'm not quite sure on
policy turns that the the what the
policy said about the mass bulk and mass
I wasn't so clear about where that is
him exactly in policy but there the
policy team and I he what officers are
saying about heritage but I'm not really
looked at that one terribly close he saw
wait for others to know Phil over to you
initially thank you Jim yes counselor
Matson asked about bulk amass I think
we've seen core strategy policy cs5
engage around that and affected me that
that the question of maintaining and
enhancing the environment and retaining
local distinctiveness that intern is
picked up by your core strategy policy
FC one which talks about an FC 1.1 which
effectively talk about proposals which
should conserve or in harm and they end
in hearts local character of different
parts of the district so you know the
question I get on I would I would put
two members these whether or not they
consider that the government does
concerning hearts local character bulk
and mass you may reference within that
and they would be they will be the
things that might drive you to that
question of local character they're all
facets of design ultimately and that
takes you onto the NPP F so those issues
are there regarding pedestrian safety
ultimately I'd probably make reference
to the National Planning policy
framework in its expectation that safe
and suitable access for all people can
be provided and I think what I'm hearing
is that the question of safe and to do
all pedestrian access is something that
you're not at present convinced can be
delivered and in turn safe and suitable
access is a facet of good design so
that's both start on that Jim it's very
helpful counselor Mansell now I was
going to make perhaps include that it
does not relate well to the existing
pattern of development which we are told
is a there's a sort of phrase that has
been used in other applications I don't
know if there is a part of a actual
policy in the MPP
but it doesn't relate well to the
existing pattern of development whether
that can be used in the argument as well
and although we've heard that it's not
isolated in art in terms of our existing
local plan
this site is deemed as in the
countryside and and surely that too can
be a reason for refusal it's not
isolated but it is in the countryside
and it is an unsustainable location
because of the no safe and safe access
for all or whatever it was that was just
in said I believe MCS to covers a lot of
that doesn't looking at core strategy -
so there's a lot in there which will
cover this castle Madison yeah we are -
two things really Ken officers just
confirm then that the cs5 and FC one and
not not inconsistent with the MPP F and
and secondly again I ask for help in
terms of the heritage response which
right so the question is cs5 and FC one
I think counselor Matson asked about and
their consistency with the NPP F well in
the best tradition of consistency
I believe the bactin inspectors said no
cs5 is not consistent with the NPP F
most recently though and if we go the
most up to date decision the Coombs Ford
decision which councillor Bruce table
I'm sure have H needed memory and the
inspectors say well I'm going to
disagree with my colleagues and he found
it to be a system with the NPP F so you
know if we go with the most recent
public inquiry that would suggest to me
that there is at least a knowledgeable
case that cs5 is consistent with the NPP
F fc-1 I'm fairly comfortable is
consistent with the NPP F you would have
to say I think that with CS 1 and CST
because they are a little more absolute
in their demands they need careful
weighing but it's councillor Mansoor
says we are dealing with a countryside
education and I think the phrase she
used about does not relate well to the
existing built-up area again this is a
this is a facet of design and ultimately
I did draw your attention to the NPP F
around good design and its expectation
and I think you're you know at liberty
as a as a committee to draw your own
conclusions about that I think I'm still
interested in whether you have any views
on the heritage side of things but I'm
kind of crystallizing in my line where
members are going I think on the
heritage side for my help although
there's no harm to actually those
properties this is a tourist area so
actually it does affect tourism it
affects the chalets across it's stolen
bars that look over that view so that
there is an effect definitely so I think
on a tourism song I think I was given
the cs2 as well isn't it yeah so that
might be a factor hopefully we're
getting there we got enough to come up
some reasons and then we can go for a
boat castle Mansell just reading the
summary of the heritage team's response
on page 186 and they do consider that
there is harm and it's low harm but
presumably we can still say that we
think that there is some harm and it is
not outweighed by any benefits elsewhere
in the scheme or whatever else chairman
you are you are entitled to agree or
disagree with your heritage officer and
away and saying that they are either
right or not as right as you are you are
the committee that makes that decision
I'm looking at the detail on page 234
and and yeah it is very much less than
substantial harm and and that is
mitigated fairly well and I think we
very easy to to say that there is a
sufficient public benefit if we were you
know kind of what to approve it so I'm
not especially okay have we got enough
to not going to include the Heritage
harm is that correct
even against tourism I mean the issue is
is that I mean I find the whole
terminology of harm
baffling you know Lester's substantial
hat harm in some respect in some
applications that's in officer to who
would say yeah well we can ignore it but
we are here to decide whether the
benefits of this application outweigh
that harm and because this development
we deemed to be unsustainable I'm not
convinced that the benefits do outweigh
the lesser substantial harm but if you
think that will weaken our case if
sometimes we're told to not have too
many reasons for refuse and other times
with we're told to have lots so I was
bowed to the wisdom of the chief
planning office thank thank you for
placing such an onerous responsibility
in giving you advice here my advice to
you is that the you should have
defensible reasons in every case and
there are you know throwing the book at
it if it's a scheme you don't like
doesn't gain new points in front of an
inspector what matters are cogent
logical defendable reasons every single
time now when it comes to heritage that
engages a very particular test in the
end PPF it engages the statutory duty to
to safeguard heritage buildings in
summary I think you know that is one
that it is in a very specific territory
which in terms of a defensible reason
you know adds considerable gravitas to
the case that you make I think that as
we've seen in bactin because we argued
it there it's an arguable point but you
as a committee are perfectly on safe
territory to engage with the weight that
you give to the public benefit balanced
against the harm and you have to have
enough public benefits to outweigh the
harm if you're going to go and approve
the application we say to you as
officers and we know what
that is met you are at liberty to
disagree but you if you do not agree
that the public benefits outweigh that
harm then you should refuse it's that
that simple I'm with that simple
explanation are we close to getting a
proposal I mean have so I think that the
tricky the tricky thing we never seen
this one before
that they you know are we I think what
cancer demands still is saying well if
we look at this in the aggregate then we
don't think there was a public benefit
because we we think we want to refuse it
for these two other reasons or are we or
is the balance against the heritage harm
just well we get some affordable houses
and and I'm that's just another question
for offices I'm a favor if that is the
advice from the chief planning officer
that it adds a gravitas well yes okay
then less inclusive I just if I may come
in Jim I think my planner colleagues
will agree that when you're it's it's a
massive as has already been said you
have advice it's your roles are
committed to sight on the level of harm
less than substantial harm we've been
reminded before in this committee is a
very large spectrum and in fact it's
what lawyers and planners call a term of
art it might be as a term it doesn't
always correspond to what an average
person would in conversation was safe
you you can do quite a bit of what an
average person would say is harm that
and it's still less and substantial
you've really got to badly harm a
heritage asset before it's substantial
harm I'm hoping to see notes from my
colleagues here I've got the right
happen tonight so I think that I just
thought was worth reminding the meeting
of that and there's the committee's job
is to decide form its own judgment
noting advice about what lobe the level
of harm is it may be less and
substantial then there still the duties
away whether it's outweighed by benefits
before I go to Kalamazoo council mass
and obviously you're the seconder on
this
I'm sorry proposes counselor Mansell
can you please come up with a reason for
refusal if that's where you going so we
can then summarize it and get on with a
vote yeah I mean that you know the two
that I'm saying is the the the the bulk
of the Malcolm s and design local
character cs5 fc-1 and the danger to
pedestrians and and vulnerable road
users I think they're called are they
cosa Mosul do you agree yeah I'm happy
to go along with that I also think that
there is some a little bit of whatever
the word is willingness about the
Heritage comments response now I've read
the papers they actually don't think the
layout is part of the outline and they
do say it is only low so I think we'd
better go along with councilor Matheson
suggestion that we just go for those two
yeah thank you sir well summarize so so
thank you chairman and we're trying to
pull the threads of this together as I
try and read this into a draft reason
for a refusal I understand that the the
proposed development does not relate
well to the existing built-up area of
storm a sport and by reason of its bulk
and mass would represent poor design
it's considered the proposed scheme
would by reason of that poor design
constitute an unsustainable form of
development considerations of the core
strategy policies cs1 cs2 cs5 and FC one
of the core strategy focused review and
B contri to paragraphs 1 to 4 and 130 of
the National Planning policy framework
that is the design paragraphs and in
turn paragraph 11 of the NPP F and on
that basis it considered that the
adverse impacts of granting Planning
Commission the adverse impacts of
development would significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits of
granting Planning Commission now as
regards the access point I would suggest
a reason which runs along the lines that
the information presently de hann does
not indicate that safe and suitable
pedestrian access for all persons
can be achieved and delivered before the
scheme is occupied country to paragraph
108 at the National Palace of the pine
policy framework and that Rosel
therefore fails to demonstrate good
design having regard to paragraphs 1 to
430 as mentioned above thank Jim
proposed to a second it's quite
comprehensive actually covers all bases
are you content with the summary thank
you
this is agenda item 70 and DC 1900 1:08
and this is for planning application
erection or a factory the journey to
story production office and other
details as before you planning officer
please Alex Thank You chairman yes
members it's explained this is
application reference DC nineteen double
zero one zero eight at cam star herbs at
chestnuts farm Langton green hi and the
proposals are in association with the
established production and supply
business dating back to 1925 the
business currently employs thirty three
full-time employees the application
proposes the erection of herb product
production factory and a warehouse
extension and canopy two-story
production office and a maintenance shed
extension to the existing yard area a
new site access from the main highway as
well as the sitting of nine mobile
accommodation units to be used by
seasonal workers and the proposal will
result in the creation of 39 full-time
employees giving a total of 72
okay yeah this is say just the back see
in red there where the site is in
relation to I and the surrounding area
and this is an aerial map of this site
and a zoomed in aerial map of the site
showing the existing facility the area
in question and these are principal
constraints and the brown hatched area
represents potentially contaminated land
in relation to the former I airfield and
existing industrial activities going on
there the site affects the setting of a
grade 2 listed building at chestnuts
farm which is over here it's great to
list it dates back from the 1600s as set
out by your heritage officers and the
report the site also lies within an area
of archaeological importance or
potential at the edge of room common and
there's the strong likelihood of
medieval assets being encountered as the
comments received from the County
archaeological unit this is the existing
site plan and the proposed site plan so
we have the proposed additional factory
here with production office at the end
and existing warehouses here and the
proposed extension is off in this
direction we have a smaller scale
maintenance shed over here
and the yard area extends this way to
the proposed new access and the mobile
home units for seasonal workers in in
this location these are the existing
elevations and the proposed elevations
so a similar height to the proposal
though a significant increase in floor
area it has to be said this is a
elevations of the proposed office
building two-story but in the context of
the larger buildings it rather pales in
to less significance I would I would say
the proposed floor plans of the office
building the proposed floor plans of the
loading dock and Factory the proposed
floor plans of the warehouse extension
which is really just shelves for the
storing of the the product the packaged
herbs and some details of the proposed
access and its ability to plays and this
shows some more detail with regard to
the access plan for the laurie's
around the site this is the foul
drainage means a foul word ranged as
proposed as you'll see in a report there
is a holding objection from the
Environment Agency in this regard they
feel it's better that the site is
connected to the existing foul
public sewer system which is adjacent to
the site within the frantic highway and
this technical matter needs to be
resolved although it's the
recommendation of your officers that
it's appropriate to do this by way of
condition and there's a condition
appropriately suggested at the at the
end of the report this plan just
provides more information on the
existing buildings and where the
proposed extensions would be on to some
photographs this is the general location
of the new access in the existing
location of a field access onto the
existing highway and the existing access
to the existing facility which is
further to the south towards eye and
looking across the existing field and up
the adjacent highway its point of access
and there again and this is looking
across towards the site but those
accessing location then turning towards
the existing warehouse building and for
a point of reference the factory will
extend in this location and this is
further to the north looking across that
adjacent field so we have the existing
attenuation pond screened by trees in
this location and the the factory
extension will extend out towards us
from this photograph but no further to
the north and the attenuation pond and
the proposed that warehouse extension
would be set behind this existing group
of trees and this is the existing niche
in the existing building where the
proposed warehouse extension would
extend off that concludes the
presentation
and as the report also recommend a tion
for approval thing Jennifer thank you
pick your Alex any questions because the
Mansell thank you I just like to ask if
there are any environmental
sustainability features of this proposed
extension which doesn't seem to have
been mentioned in the report I know that
there are regulations but I just wonder
what the proposals are I guess they meet
the regulations but do they go beyond as
whether the extent very leveled
information provided with the
application apart from solar panels to
the southern elevation of that large
warehouse extension as you'll see only
not can I just come back on that because
I think I mean I'm not okay with all the
facts and figures in the regulations but
there is a requirement for a certain
percentage of energy to be provided by
sustainable means is that right and and
is that that is presumably along with
this application sorry do you mean in
terms of building regulations and there
are but when we talk about industrial
sites before we're told that there is a
per se a target for the percentage of
energy to be generated by sustainable
means I think can't some Matheson's
jumping on you can yeah councilman thank
you yeah thank you yeah my my question
was have you have you emitted to include
in the conditions that are proposed the
the recommendation on page page 239
where the consul tears as pointed out
that there should be a 10% on-site
renewables provision but it's not clear
whether the what's on this drawings is
sufficient it's actually there but it's
not in the conditions yet but it will be
in a minute
I think so what page is that again thank
you
yet noted so yeah we might think about
it for a condition as we move on yeah
we'll wait for debate I oppose any other
questions Cass Brewster I think you have
a more we're on conditions and if I may
have missed this but if I do if I have I
apologize we the colors of the the
shades to be agreed yeah that's a good
point so we did a pre briefing on this
obviously and the matter of the color of
the buildings was discussed as you know
with model buildings now in a
countryside especially where they've got
height there's is a camouflage scheme
where you go blue tip like light blue
the current ones are green there's
enough backdrop there to support that I
think but let's get some more
clarification on the backdrop and
whether the green would be suitable
thank you are there any other questions
brilliant we'll move straight onto the
ward member then Peter King
Thank You Jenna I'm going to do five
today's conventional ward councillors
speaking against applications and I'd
say you would have seen that I tank out
so I have no objections to this proposal
which is which is that perfectly true
but that doesn't reflect the positive
view it is taken in terms of this
development the applicant makes a
significant important contribution
towards the local economy and that's a a
contribution that can be extended
valuably extended through this
application have been agreed the I think
the positives within it also in terms of
the
the expansion of this site will reduce
the need for inter-site the applicants
into site vehicle movements and that has
to be a positive I had to say from a
road up safety aspect as well the moving
the entrance to the factory northwards
will improve road safety the present
entrance is quite close to abandoned
vehicles turning right out of that well
it's a slightly powerless activity
obviously the point about the color of
the units is is well made but and on
hopes that will be the case but
certainly what is presented is a farm
will have a far more coherent and
acceptable appearance even though it is
greatly increased in scale than then
present I call them a motley arrangement
of buildings so fully in support of this
application from the water Thank You
councillor Mansell thank you you
mentioned the applicants other site and
this do you think that this will reduce
traffic movements because they'll all be
based on one side can you just tell me
where that other site is right there's a
site in Broome but there's also a site
across the across the road are on the
airfield itself so I mean obviously the
increase in the size of the factory
potentially increases the volume
business that this is done and that may
arise in an increased number of vehicles
but actually in terms of the present
scale of business inter-site movements
will be reduced and that obviously goes
to be true of that even given the
expansion the number of internal
movements as it were
would still be fewer than would
otherwise be the case and the other
thing which is a particular mercy
in this application so many applications
in and around I particularly commercial
ones result in have are resulting in
greatly increased traffic and HTV
movements in the in the southern part of
the time and the town centre so this is
to the north of the town so won't be
adding to that pressure any other
questions
excellent I'm gonna move into debate so
who'd like to start
cuz the war boy I am familiar with the
area and I think this would be a
positive development there is one issue
which comes to do is sort of the
development though which is one of the
concerns of situated to do with like
pollution this has been raised on
several developments in the area and I
wonder if that could be put in with
reserve matters that as part of the
planning that might pollution and a
lighted scheme could be developed that
would mitigate this thank Jamie yes I
invest politicians of things I was going
to suggest if you see page 239
councillor Matson did query a question
about energy but actually we we also
need to add a condition relating to
noise and to light because that's
recommended by environmental health on
page 2 8 1 you'll see and I think it's a
fair summary if you can leave that one
with officers to take away I think it's
well understood that light spill in the
area of a field is a matter of interest
in dark skies or amount of interest so
there's a there's a noise condition
suggested there by the scene univeral
Protection Officer and we would want to
take away the idea of a lighting scheme
to be agreed as a suggested condition in
addition to those you've got a new
Thank You dosa Matson well with with
various additional conditions I'd like
to move approval
clearly this is a business it's right in
the heart of our economy the
agricultural economy and so I think with
the conditions we're adding are the the
10% plus renewable energy the lighting
the noise and also the other one that's
actually missing that we usually have
there is a game of resource and water
efficiency because he's a full
application isn't it that's the other
one
so with those with those additions I can
say Brewster Thank You mr. chairman and
I should probably done this sooner but
you're in the meeting just looking at
this I've had no part in this
application whatsoever and wasn't even
aware of it until I saw that the the
papers come through I'm just wondering
from a cabinet point of view whether I
should still time to and it's I'm sure
it's not peculiar yes in Cass's we've in
the past we have had discussions about
your role in the cabinet there's it's
restricted to if you've made a specific
decision regarding it as your cabinet
function just knowing about the business
or being involved through it that way is
with regards to funds specifically that
would preclude you from taking so
Kennedy's confirming it you've made no I
have made so we have a proposal do we
have a second that counsel Mansell thank
you I would just like to say that I
think this is it's quite refreshing to
have a business in the heart of our
district who is wanting to expand and I
would like to wish them all the best
come what may at the end of October and
I hope they still get a load of season
stuff but that's that's not for us to
decide so I actually I think it's it's
great that we've got a thriving company
that is wanting to develop and stay in
mid Suffolk and I think we should be
supporting them in their expansion and I
agree that we need a few extra
conditions so I'm happy to second the
motion proposed by councillor Matheson
with those extra conditions if that's
possible to put them on yeah thank you
and absolutely the MPP F supporting the
prosperous world economy what could be
better and it's appropriate place as
well so great summarized please yes
thank Janet yes so adding a condition to
secure a scheme of energy efficiency
measures to be agreed which to achieve
at least ten percent energy efficiency
that goes along with cs3 is talking
sorry yes well if I'm if I'm fighting
you are ahead of me cows behind Paula
Jones I'm not quite with you yet so the
second one was the noise condition which
is a spur page 281 and as regards the
light recommendation we'd expect to
draft a condition to grace a scheme of
external lighting for agreement in line
with what to talked about on page 281
and the fourth condition would affect me
to agree a scheme of resource and water
efficiency we all believe it's working
as the mass murder yeah that's a very
good point we almost missed out I think
that should be a condition as well to be
to be considered because you might find
the Greens absolutely fine I'm so to
propose that and ii don't agree with the
conditions as stated okay to propose it
ii defer approval all those in favor i'm
so gender point sorry agenda point eight
site inspections
none requested chef thank you and moving
on to the date and time of next meeting
the next meeting will be on Wednesday
2nd of October 2019 at 9:30 a.m. and
thank you for contribution thank you
very work was appreciated and that's the
meeting closed